Ladies, gentlemen, and non-biny-finies, welcome to WrestleTuber 2024 Day 2!
Day 1 was an intense day of London bridges, colorful characters, and a bit of scuff.
But what surprises await us today?
Stay tuned!
And now, presenting your overlord, your caster, the one, the only, Donkey!
Oh my god, wow!
I did not expect that intro!
Oh my god, just need you guys to know, he was very nervous before we started.
He was like, I don't know what to say guys.
Oh wow, that was amazing!
Give it up for our announcer there!
Woo!
Anyway, welcome to Day 2 of WrestleTuber!
What we'll be doing for Day 2 is the remaining brackets and then the finals!
To find out who will be the champion of WrestleTuber 2024!
Very exciting day today.
We actually have, it's a little less scuffed.
They're still gonna be scuffed because I am a one man opioid.
I am a BS person.
But we did improve the tech and behind the scenes for all of you guys.
So I hope you guys, look I even have my own, like we even had time to afford a custom headset as well.
Instead of the default headset.
But we actually have a set schedule for the casters as well as what the matches are.
So I'll give you guys the rundown of the brackets and who's gonna be casting who.
Mint and I will be casting the finals.
The last couple of final matches.
So at the first set of rotations, we actually have two special guests that will be doing, that will be casting the show matches for us.
We have someone that has been in the actual WWE!
Casting the show match with BuffBuff, Blue Sea, Maryletter and Shy Lily.
And so our special guest is actually Jibo.
If you guys don't know who Jibo is, he was in the actual WWE Mason Mace.
If you guys don't remember Mason...
He was actually in WWE.
And he will be doing the casting with Taka for the show match.
I'm sorry, it's not John Cena.
Sorry, Mason D Madden.
It is not...
Guys, it is not John Cena.
I mean technically he could be there.
He could just be in the background.
We don't really know.
You can't really see him.
Anyway, so for the brackets.
After the show match.
After the tag team show match.
This will be our bracket for the day.
It's a little bit more professional now.
So the very first match after the brackets.
Sorry, after the show match.
Will be Fuyo versus Snuffy.
Then after that, whoever wins that match will be against Nana.
And then whoever wins that match will be against Emma.
And then after that, we have bracket two.
This bracket will be casted by Snuffy and Fillion.
So right after the show matches with our guest casters.
Taka and Jibo.
We will have Snuffy and Fillion casting these matches.
In bracket two.
Sorry, this is the original.
I just say there will be a little bit of scuff.
They will also be casting Luto versus Sayu as well.
After that, we will rotate our casters.
With Kai and Octavio.
Unfortunately, Gerard has to...
Gerard has to...
Is sick right now.
So he will be substituted by Kai.
And from there, they will be casting the winner of the Luto versus Sayu match against Anon.
And then after that, they will be casting for the two of the final matches.
For the final matches.
For the final bracket.
Mint and I will be spinning a wheel.
To dictate who will be facing who in the final bracket.
And from then on...
And then we find the champion!
Yay!
It's going to be a very exciting day.
I hope you guys will enjoy day two.
It's going to be very fun.
I'm so excited.
And I'm really...
Happy with...
How...
Like talented everybody was.
How incredible everyone was.
From day one.
And everybody's hard efforts.
And all the participants.
So far in WrestleTuber.
I hope you guys will enjoy day two!
Everybody!
I really do hope you guys will enjoy day two.
Anyway!
From then on...
Remember!
Remember...
Do you guys remember what the belt looks like?
Because whoever is going to win this show match...
Will be bringing this belt...
Home tonight!
Well not tonight.
They still have to ship it.
But they get the PNG tonight!
Alright!
Well I guess that's it for me in the main casting chair.
So let's go over to our guest casters.
In the interview section.
Bye guys!
What a day for wrestling!
Let me tell you it's great to be here.
Back to VTubing after 10 months.
Alongside you Yebo!
Taka it is pandemonium in the WrestleDrome!
How are you feeling tonight?
You had to come out of hiatus.
I had to come out of retirement.
This is a big fight feel!
Oh without a shadow of a doubt.
Night one was explosive.
So that means night two will be implosive.
It expands and now it retracts.
And as it retracts more things will be colliding in the center of that squared circle.
Ladies and gentlemen.
Yeah I'm going to explode all over the place Taka.
We are both guest casting here tonight.
I am Yellow Snow Taka Hata.
And I am joined by Dick Inky Yebo.
Yes you can call me Dick Inky.
That is my commentary name.
I'm the only person here to have Vince McMahon yapping in my ear during commentary during a horrible Hell in a Cell match.
Tonight I've got Doki in my ear.
So if I say anything bad it's her fault.
There we go.
You got it.
You confirmed it right here.
She is the master of this domain.
Her domain has expanded to encapsulate professional wrestling as well.
And we're up for a heck of a first bout here.
Because I believe we're having a mixtag action.
And I believe we have an interview set to be taking away.
Please take us away Juna.
Hello.
Thank you so much.
Right now we have...
We have...
Oh I'm sorry.
Oh it's so cute.
We have Mary, Lucy, Shy Lily and the buff pup here.
Right now they are...
That's me.
You scared me.
We were talking and we like got thrown in here and I got scared.
I was like what happened?
I am God.
I took you here.
You should have waited.
Yes, all to the inside.
Lay your praises upon me for I have arrived.
Amazing.
Incredible.
Our show match will be consisting of two tag teams.
Consisting of Mary and buff pup and Lucy and Shy Lily.
So for the two dog pros.
We are going to have a little bit of a battle.
How are you feeling about this match so far?
Well I'm...
When it comes to double D's that's what we are.
We are the double D crew.
Okay.
I feel very confident.
Just because dogs get things done.
So.
Yeah.
They do.
Dogs back where it's gone.
Well they got sort of bones.
That's true.
I'm certain we are going to win because I've got buff pup.
So I mean they are done.
That's true.
And also like I like bones so like if I make Shy Lily and Lucy a skeleton then I can just take them.
So.
Oh I see.
Yeah.
Oh I didn't think about that.
I'll give you a scratch.
Well what do the two cute girls have to say in response?
I want buff to sit on my face.
Alright done.
Easy.
I mean I'm a...
I got a bone that you can chew on.
But it's not much of a...
Tension.
What about a bone?
It's not about resting it's about just like body contact with way too much skin.
Yeah honestly like if I win or lose like I think I'm winning regardless so.
You know.
I'm winning either way.
I'm a great...
I'm happy to hear that there's great sportsmanship and skinship here.
With all of the contestants in the show match.
Well other than being choked cold and being sat on.
I hope you guys do well in the ring.
Thank you.
And good luck.
Yes of course.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Goodbye.
Goodbye!
Please fight me.
Goodbye.
See you.
Bye.
Now I gotta say, one tag team is absolutely gorgeous.
Well, they're both gorgeous, to be honest, but one team does appear to have that dog in them.
That dog is very important when it comes to a professional wrestling match, Taka.
Because they can run around on all fours like a hound.
But so can cats.
That's true.
But not like hounds, but like cats.
Speaking of cats and dogs, that's what this scrap is gonna be all about, let me tell you.
It's like a feral free-for-all.
A fo-ree-for-all.
A fo-for-for-for-free-for-all, correct.
Absolutely.
Now I gotta, I gotta get, let's take it away to our ring announcer.
In this corner, you can hear them barking from two corners of the planet.
You have the Buff Bro Buff Pop and...
The tension is palpable, I do not know what they're about to say.
Well, what's happening right now is the, is the big dog is making their entrance singles, because they are not...
Taking their sweet time.
I mean, when you look at this buff, you look this talented, you look this amazing, you'd take your time too, basking in this adulation from this wonderful capacity.
And I'm not gonna lie, I'm not gonna lie.
You have a capacity crown of over 13,000 people in the Wrestler Trooper Dome.
What are we right now, Taka?
What?
What, what state are we in right now?
A state of denial, Yebo!
Yes, yes, that's the correct answer.
Because no one can deny it.
You can see everybody in the audience here tonight.
How buff this pup is.
Where does that tail go?
Oh Rob...
Ring announcer!
I love this guy!
And in this corner, you have the Buff Bro Buff Pop.
See, that is a classy outfit there.
It looks expensive, it looks velvety.
I can appreciate Meriwether getting a custom model just for this occasion with their symbol on the back.
Money, money, money, money, money, money, money, money, money.
Money, money, money, money.
Usually people smoke in that jacket, but he may end up smoking the competition in it.
Let's see if he can make it rain on his competition tonight.
And their opponent...
coming in from the other side of the ring...
it's not just Lucy Juicy...
it's Lucy Pyre!
Now hold on now, Taka.
Did she just wake up?
Clearly she was napping in the back.
They got themselves a coffee.
They still have brought the blanket because they're not fully awake.
You know that thing when you wake up in the morning and you're like, I'm gonna go get my coffee.
And like, you know, I appreciate the dedication to taking some time to get some sleep.
Because the one thing you don't want to do is sleep on the competition.
And that might be what happens...
I just wonder if...
I just wonder if she's fully prepared for what's going on today.
It looks like she's still napping.
Doesn't matter where or when he's competing...
Well, hopefully she starts with rest holds to start the match.
And maybe they'll wake up from there.
Oh yeah.
That's a little insider baseball for you guys in the chat.
That's for all the smarks in the audience.
All the smart marks.
And her teammate...
coming in...
she's not just a wailing gotcha girl.
She's...
It's...
Shyalily.
Alright, from the bedroom to the pool house.
Maybe they were sleeping in the same place.
Maybe they were sleeping in the pool house.
Either way, Shyalily...
Womp womp indeed, ladies and gentlemen.
I have seen how she has destroyed a pineapple.
This person can destroy the competition.
The crowd is whomping.
What did she destroy the pineapple with?
You know what?
It's best left unsaid.
Interesting.
And the crowd is whomping.
Don't you see the whompage happening in the audience?
You can hear them whomping.
Whomplamania.
Whomplamania is running wild.
Whomp!
Look at the eyes.
The eyes tell a story.
The eyes don't lie and the eyes spell disaster tonight at Sacrifice.
The apex mammal of our species.
And their opponents are in for a whale of a time.
That's pretty good, Taka.
Thank you.
You should get a raise.
You know what?
Maybe.
Maybe if you're good.
Speaking of good, this match is brought to you by Gamersups, everybody.
Thank you.
For all of you attending this wonderful event.
And let's get this thing started with some tag team action.
Let's get it on!
Oh, it's a tornado tag.
Look at the size of Buff Pup.
Now, Taka, I'm a bit of a tag team aficionado myself.
I'm undefeated on the independence.
Champion in multiple countries.
So if you have any questions for how to win a tornado tag team match, feel free to ask me.
Okay.
So as a whomp...
So now, if you're the biggest person in the tag match like Buff Pup is, how do you avoid getting targeted by the wily, small, tiny ones?
Just like that.
You do a thes press and you beat the pulp out of the face, Taka.
If you stay off the ground, they can't put you on the ground.
And look at that!
Whoa!
Look at that!
She just sat on her!
That cake-based offense.
Now, Mary just grabbed a sledgehammer from underneath the ring.
Now, this is an Extreme Rules tornado tag match.
And this is essentially a complete anarchy already.
Shia Lili's got a steel chair!
She got a steel chair!
Anything goes!
Narrowly avoiding the chair.
Buff Pup avoiding the damage, locking up with Shia Lili yet again.
And Shia Lili decides to walk the dog to the ropes.
Oh, if you put the dog on the leash, they're not gonna like that very much, Taka.
Oh, and just kneeling!
Lucy!
Oh, and that's exactly what you need to do against a larger opponent, Taka.
You gotta chop the tree down.
Break down the legs.
And make sure they have nothing to walk on.
Corkscrew leg dri- corkscrewing them!
Oh, picking apart all the limbs.
Oh, a pin attempt is being made!
That's not just a pin, that's a sexy pin.
Sidewalk slam maybe?
Yes!
Oh, I believe they call that deep pin attration.
It rhymes with attrition.
Makes me wanna get back in the ring, Taka.
It does.
I mean, you gotta be feeling enamored by these superstars.
In the ring, Buff Pup laying in an absolute clinic!
Oh, now the numbers game.
Now you've fought many different tag teams.
How would you handle someone with the size and buffness of Buff Pup?
Well, honestly, Taka, I've never been in the ring with somebody bigger than me.
I'm approximately 9 feet tall and 800 pounds.
But, there was somebody who was...
Oh my god!
What a sledgehammer throw!
They threw a sledgehammer at Lucy Pyre's head!
Absolutely no regard for human society and wellness.
Well-being.
They say dog is man's best friend, but they can also be your worst enemy if you cross him.
Oh, lookit, that's Chekov's table right there.
Somebody's gotta go through it by the end of the match.
Otherwise, everybody's going to be disappointed.
One armed...
Press!
That's the size advantage there, Taka.
Oh, and a knuckle shuffle!
That wasn't all five.
That was just four knuckles.
We see Mary going again for another item.
Pulling in a trash can!
About to take out the trash!
Somebody says, you know Waifu is trash.
Mary saying that Lucy Pyre belongs to the trash.
Oh, what a beautiful move by Buff Puff there.
It looks to me like the dogs are in control.
The dog... and now going for a sneaky pin here.
Like, hold on!
Kick out at one, but we got a table!
We have a table at play!
The crowd is going wild.
They're saying, tables, tables, tables!
Oh, nice!
This is hard to even call.
Now it looks like the team of Shia Lillie and Lucy have managed to start matching up with the dogs a little bit more.
Now trying to keep pace.
Lucy grabbing the garbage can she was placed in.
Oh!
I thought we were going to see a double team on the outside.
Perhaps being sandwiched between the trash can and two dogs.
Oh!
Shia Lillie throwing... but...
What a rolling damage there to Buff Puff who was slammed into the grate.
As Mary is picking apart.
Lucy Pyre on the other side.
The dogs are firmly in control here tonight, Taka.
The dogs are barking!
And that's not just from the audience, folks.
The dogs are getting overly worked out.
They can tire themselves out without even realizing it.
And that's the challenge.
Can their singular...
Oh!
Just threw that in the back of Shia Lillie's head!
Unbelievable!
Now Taka, that's actually a great point.
Could the dogs have started off really hot and maybe tuckered themselves out before the match is over?
Is this a game of attrition?
It really depends.
Are they in the small dog park or the big dog park?
Well, I see a couple of big dogs and a couple of people in the audience are chanting for the big dogs.
But I guess we'll find out who, when they win tonight.
Lucy being double teamed by Mary and Buk Buk Buk Buk striking a pose.
Taunting.
Arrogance.
We'll have to see if that comes back to bite them.
But Lucy grabbing an item from under the ring.
Well, Lucy grabs it from under the ring, but no!
Buk Buk's gonna... Oh!
Beautiful!
Oh.
Turning neck breaker into even more offense.
Shia Lillie taunting the opponents to get into the ring.
What is this?
What is Shia Lillie going for here?
And that's a beautiful back body drop!
Lucy's on fire!
Will that be enough for Buk Buk Buk?
Break up by Shia Lillie.
This is the danger of a tornado match.
Oh!
A big dog punch!
Blood.
Kick out at two.
Only two.
That was close, Taka.
What is Buk Buk doing?
That's 500 pounds of... Oh, never mind.
We're good.
No, that's smart.
He's too big to go up there.
Just taking out...
Just taking out Shia Lillie.
Oh.
Oh my gosh.
She's got a family.
2-on-1 beatdown.
Oh!
And Lucy takes a steel chair to the head from Mary.
Oh, pop up drop kick.
Well, a reverse.
Shia Lillie reversing it.
Oh!
And a drop kick from Mary.
This is...
This is getting hard to watch, Taka.
Oh, this is some PWG-style wrestling right now.
Oh my god!
Buk Buk with the sledgehammer!
Haunting the opponents.
They've been pretty cocky since the start of this match.
Oh!
Hitting Mary!
Buk Buk just hit Mary in the back of the head!
Couldn't take advantage.
She couldn't take advantage of the miscommunication and they are back on the same page.
The dogs are in sync.
Silently thrown away.
Lucy Pyre grabbing hold of Mary, throwing Mary back in the ring.
Pinfalls have to occur inside the ring to my knowledge.
And Lucy...
That's very true.
Oh!
Pulling Buk Buk...
What's this?
Oh!
My goodness!
Tope!
Tope Shua Shida!
Mama mia!
Buk Buk is... What is Buk Buk thinking right now?
Oh!
Into the steps!
Oh, gosh.
Somebody's got to go through that table, Taka.
Bad booking.
Someone has to.
We have three tables at play right now and...
Oh!
Back in the...
Back in the head!
But it's not in the ring.
It's not in the ring.
Oh!
Mary had the kendo stick knocked out of their hand.
Buk Buk is observing.
This is their chance.
This could be it.
He's woofin' up.
And now the teams are... Now they're both targeting.
They're going after Lucy again!
And there... It's that pack-a-dog mentality, Taka.
Never mind.
Mary has decided to switch up and go after Shia...
Oh!
Miss!
Did they hit?
Oh, no.
They did hit.
Wow.
It's really not... It's really not safe to be throwing these weapons around.
Don't throw kendo sticks!
It's not a... Oh!
Blood on the outside!
Buk
Buk is taking apart Lucy.
And Shia Lily makes Mary pay for it on the outside.
In all my years, I don't think I've ever seen a match this brutal.
What is... What is Buk Buk doing on the outside?
On the outside!
That's the hardest part of the ground, Taka!
Back of the... Back of the head!
Whoa!
Oh, my God!
Mary almost tapped out!
Mary almost tapped out there for a second!
This could be it.
Oh, now she's bleeding too.
Mary going for a pin.
Is that it?
One... Two...
Oh, that's it!
She was so close!
Last second!
Your winners...
Give a good ol' bark...
For the dogs...
Meriwether...
And Bufpo!
Not only did they have those dogs in them, those dogs won.
Now their opponents have their dog in them too.
Man's best friend... Man's worst enemy.
Taka, what do you think... What did you expect going into that match?
Did you expect that outcome?
I actually expected Shia Lili to be bigger than Buf Pop.
Whales are very big.
Yeah, yeah, they start off pretty big, but big dogs stand on top.
That's true.
We're also on land, so...
Wow.
Physical position.
What a show!
I can't believe...
The Double Ds, they won?
What...
I need to ask, I must ask the two cute girls.
How did it feel having a very buff big dog come at you with a sledgehammer?
I would be shitting my pants if I was in your position.
I need to see her after that.
Why was she so big?
Why did she... Oh my god!
Why was she...
Where the...
Is that as good for you as it was for me, Pop?
Honestly, I was scared.
There was one point where I thought I was going to get like 18 plus and I was really nervous.
I was like...
Oh my god, I feel so bad.
I literally was like bashing everyone's head with a sledgehammer.
I don't know what the heck came over me.
I need a rabies vaccine after.
Well, yeah, we both get exposed to something.
It seems to be the we...
We have to call 911 again.
911, please.
Please.
Well, for the Double D team...
Round two?
Round...
No, it's either, bro.
We'll do round two next weekend.
Okay, okay.
Am I okay?
Okay.
Well...
Well, does the Double T have any...
I think he needs to be put down.
I need backup.
Please.
Patrick, what I have...
Help.
I need...
Hello?
Cut the cameras.
I need help.
Help.
Please.
Don't worry about it.
Just...
It's the rabies.
It's the rabies?
It's okay.
Okay.
That dog needs to be neutered.
It's okay.
I'm my dog alone.
He's fine.
He's just excited.
Don't worry.
Buff got this.
She got it under control.
Don't worry about it.
You saw in the match.
She had to like put him in place as well in the match.
I did.
I hit him in the back of the head with a sledgehammer.
She had no friends.
Only in the football match.
That was my warning shot.
I love wrestling.
I love it.
Just give him a second in the crate.
He'll be all right after.
In the crate?
All right.
I understand.
He just...
He still needs crate training.
He's just a puppy.
He needs to be trained and leashed.
Well...
Well, do...
Thank you so much for the show match.
Do any of you guys have any words for the upcoming matches?
Like any match that you're going to be playing?
I think I'm going to be playing the motivational speeches that you could possibly give them.
I better see some bloodshed.
I better see some double D action out there.
Okay.
I want to see some flinging, some flying, some barking even.
Maybe some sweat.
Some spitting.
I need sweat and blood and sweat and sweat.
And I hope it gets sweaty.
I think we're getting a preview for next week's meet up.
Thank you, ladies and gentlemen, for joining us for our show match.
Show match.
Where, next week?
I am so sorry.
I'm okay.
It was a pleasure having you guys here, I hope...
Thank you for shutdown me.
I hope all of you guys get baby shock.
I'm going to get through.
Oh, god.
We got them.
We delete us every week.
They've got too much of that dog in them, Dick Inky.
I will say that.
Somebody call Animal Control, because that animal is out of control.
Absolutely.
Thank you, guys!
Thank you for being the guest caster for this show.
And this is the show match!
I guess this is behind the scenes Doki here.
We're gonna be going back to the main stage everybody.
But let's say a huge thank you to everybody here for the show matches and the winners of the show match, the dogs.
I was very surprised they beat the anime girls.
But I guess...
I was the dog.
Every dog has its day!
Some of the girls might need some rabies shots later.
Anyway, say thank you to all the people there.
We're gonna go back to the main stage to get ready for the tournament.
Thank you!
Bye bye guys!
Oh, wow I forgot to take the belt off.
Hey!
Like I said, thank you to the people at the show match.
That was fucking extraordinary.
It was like a last minute change.
I know originally it was like a tornado tag.
But then I decided to change it to extreme because I was like...
Whoa!
They can like throw hammers?
So I had to include it.
Again a huge shout out to our guest casters.
Give me a sec.
I want to be sure if...
Snuffy and Fillion are ready to cast the beginning of the tournament.
So give me a sec.
I'm going to check as I cue them in.
Guys, one man army here.
If they're not ready, we will have a little change of casters.
We might have Kai and Octavio to start us off.
So just give me a sec as I check it out here.
But for those who are waiting, for those who are waning, the first match is not this one.
That is not the first match.
The first match was technically Fuyo versus Snuffy.
But at the moment, I am not sure if Snuffy is in the ring at the moment.
So if we do not have...
If Snuffy is not here yet, we might have Octavio and Kai come over to do bracket 2, I believe.
To do bracket 2.
For Araka and Luto.
So for now, at the moment, I don't believe Snuffy is in the stadium at the moment.
So we are going to have a little, slight change of the casters.
And we are going to have Kai and Octavio to come in to cast for Luto and Sayu.
So give me a sec everybody.
As I ping, let them know.
Um...
Oh, they should know.
They are in this call.
Kai and Octavio, are you guys ready to cast the first match?
Kai and Octavio.
Pinging Kai and Octavio.
You guys can talk.
Oh, we can talk?
Okay.
Yeah, we can talk.
You guys can talk in the headset to let me know.
I'm just sending emojis.
What is this?
It's like...
I was like...
We are here.
You guys are here.
That is good to know.
I was a little worried when I didn't get any response.
No one's here for some reason.
We were in the break room.
Yeah, yeah.
When we were pinging them from the break room, I had to be sure they were here and ready to cast before I rotate them in.
But yes, thank you again to Kai for substituting for me.
And thank you to Gerard for the interview.
Are you guys ready to cast for your first match?
Do you guys remember what your first match is?
Yes!
Who are they?
Before I send you over to the interview table.
Um...
Oh, shit.
Who are they?
Yeah!
Sending you over to the interview stage.
I hope you guys are already sitting down, guys.
Oh, yeah.
I'm running.
Whoa!
Oh, shit!
Sorry, I just...
You're gigantic!
I'm sorry.
It's all gas in there.
There's nothing.
It's empty.
Hello, hello!
Sorry, I'm trying to peer over the desk.
There we go.
Hi, everyone!
And welcome to Day 2.
There's been some really, really exciting matches.
And I hope you guys are ready for the...
Fucking shit.
That's about to go down today.
How are you feeling, Octavio?
I'm feeling great.
And, you know, we are a follow-up to the awesome Taka and Jibo earlier.
They have actual WWE experience.
We do have actual WWE experience, too.
Yesterday.
Oh, yeah, yeah, no, for sure.
Yeah.
And then I lost.
And then... That counts, though, right?
That counts.
For sure.
I won, then I lost.
So we're both losers here.
And I think that's great.
We're the perfect people.
Yeah, no, it's great, you know.
It'll bring, like, a good perspective, I think.
Alright?
Mm-hmm.
Absolutely.
From the perspective of those who who will never make it in the WWE.
Okay, just how sad would you put it?
Just how sad!
Alright.
But hello, everybody.
Yeah.
Where are our wrestlers?
Are they here?
We are currently waiting for them to come from the back.
Whoa!
Oh, they're coming!
They're coming!
They sure are coming!
Oh my god!
We're waiting for them to become smaller!
I'm sorry.
I guess red people today just have really big heads.
I don't know.
It's just how it is.
What's up with that?
I don't know.
Strangely.
But... Buta?
Excuse me?
What?
Don't make me jump over this table.
I will fight you right now.
Okay.
Short bitch.
Professional.
Anyways.
Damn.
Who's fighting here?
I'm not quite sure.
Listen.
It should be me in the ring.
It should be me.
But it's okay.
I'll be professional.
It's fine.
We'll lock in.
Whoa.
We not...
I'm waiting for a response.
Are they here?
Oh wait.
True.
I think Luto might still be in the break room.
Maybe having some cheese and crackers.
Who knows?
But...
Honestly though.
Honestly.
While we wait.
I just want to say.
I am very excited to be substituted in.
I saw that we were missing a red reptile.
And I was like.
Oh shit.
Wait.
I'm also a red reptile.
This will work.
Yeah.
The other reptile.
Extinct already.
So that's fine.
It's over.
It's the age of the dragon now.
Yeah.
Fuck that.
This is better.
This is way better.
You think so?
Yeah.
Definitely.
You know what?
Here's the thing.
Yesterday I was beaten by a dragon.
I mean.
I beat a dragon.
Oh really?
And now I'm casting with a dragon.
So I think that's character development for me.
Yeah.
True.
Although I think you're crazy.
Because I don't think you'd beat a dragon.
But anyway.
That's crazy.
That's just like my opinion.
That's the way I want to see things.
You can't beat a dragon.
But you know.
It's fine.
You know.
If you want to lie like that.
That's cool.
Fair and square fight.
No.
I didn't see nothing.
Well I saw your fight.
No you didn't.
And you got beaten.
Within like three minutes.
I don't think you saw anything.
And I think you're crazy.
And I think you're strange for saying that actually.
Excuse me.
You had the biggest trash talk in the beginning too.
You were like.
I'm going to split this lime into two.
And squirt it into your eyes.
Oh my god.
You did watch.
Okay.
Down.
That's embarrassing.
Okay.
Down.
I would have rather you not perceive me.
Alright.
No.
Okay.
Listen.
I needed to at least like.
I'm a firm believer in like manifestation.
Alright.
If you want something to happen.
You gotta believe.
It's gonna happen.
Alright.
So I'm like.
You know what.
I'm gonna.
Hell yeah.
I'm gonna beat her fucking ass.
I'm gonna fucking win.
But you know what.
Sometimes it just.
That's a lot of talk coming from down here.
It doesn't turn out that way sometimes.
The losers bracket casting.
But trust me.
If it was me and June on the ring.
I would have won.
No.
We already know.
It was just a bad moment.
I would not chip on my end.
We've already met up and we talked about this.
No.
I'm sorry.
Again.
I'm manifesting.
I would literally be.
Stop calling me puta.
You fucking puta.
I literally beat you.
I think we need a show match.
Do you see.
Do you see what I have to put up with?
We are getting some response from Luto Real.
Not Clickbait.
She's on her way.
She's just grabbing some snacks.
And there she is.
Sayu.
Luto.
Are you here?
So that's what my opponent sounds like?
Yep.
This is definitely Luto.
Damn.
Are you in today, Sayu?
Yes.
I'm excited to be here.
It'll be my debut as a wrestler.
It's gonna be great.
Raiden, Luto.
How will you defeat someone that's, you know, four or three times your size?
With my Australian powers.
And demon powers.
Demon powers?
Australian demon powers.
Yes, because all demons come from Australia.
This is true.
Oh shit.
Exactly.
Kangaroos are fucking terrified.
They're weird.
Yeah, kangaroos and koalas.
They're like demonic.
They're scary.
They shouldn't exist.
I'm very excited to see how this will end up.
An Australian versus an American?
The AA?
Yeah, sure, sure.
I don't know.
I'm unsure.
I'm so sorry.
You're okay.
It's my first day on the job.
I am gonna win.
Where's this shit talking?
You're not gonna win.
You're just a little robo boy.
Can't handle all this...
kangaroo.
And you're a son of a bitch who's gonna die.
What?
Yeah, tell them all.
Well...
Yeah, well, for real.
I'm intimidated.
I think they're ready.
I'm feeling the energy.
I'm feeling the tension.
It's actually kind of scary.
What the heck?
Yeah, I'm scared.
You shake it, I'm shaking.
I'm gonna bring my kangaroo.
You're gonna bring a kangaroo?
I'll bring out two kangaroos.
I'll bring out my computer to smack the shit out of you with.
I'll bring...
even more computers.
I'm sorry.
I am not sorry.
That's not your seagull laugh.
I'm just like...
What is going on?
Damn.
Well, I think they're ready to go into the ring.
Yeah, they could take you to the ring.
I wanna see how this goes there.
The Australian and the American.
Oh, jeez, I gotta look over the table again.
I'm sorry.
I'm too short.
Okay, there we go.
They got the step stool.
Thank you.
Alright, who do you think's gonna win?
I'm actually...
That's scary.
That's actually demonic.
Look at Luto there.
Yeah, Luto's actually got... I'm terrified.
Honestly, my money was on Sayu, but after hearing that kangaroo stuff, I don't know.
I'm scared.
True, true.
And honestly, Sayu just looks like a guy.
Yeah, bro's just a dude.
Like, it's like...
One little guy against a fucking demon from Australia.
I'm sorry.
True.
I wouldn't be scared.
Just look at that hair, that mustache, those horns.
Ah, Dan's too intimidating.
Here we go.
In this corner...
We have...
The handsomest tech support around...
Totally not biased.
It's...
Sayu!
Definitely not biased.
Let's fucking go!
Yeah!
He's announcing himself.
Wow.
That's kinda... That's kinda a new look.
If you think about it.
Hey, shush!
It's just you telling me, shush!
I do love how he's staying on brand.
Like, on board, right foot forward as well.
Look at this.
Oh.
He's figuring it out.
Oh, there he goes.
Into the ring he rolls, and alright.
A competitor who always has his...
It's funny because he's just tech support.
Ready for a major battle.
And he's doing this.
Honestly, I get surprised at how well you customize these.
Holy fuck.
And now...
Coming to the stage...
After grabbing...
Oh.
Okay.
The suspense!
It's Ludo!
Eh, Yasqueen!
Look at that slay!
Let's fucking go!
I didn't expect this very bright outfit.
Bright pink, blue and yellow.
Bright is the way to go though.
It makes you look flashy, alright.
You get extra style points.
I love the holographic horns too.
It's a vibe.
It's her world and we're just living in it.
Really.
Her weird Australian little world.
Actually, wait.
I can't remember.
You got that headphone thing.
You know how the skull gets compressed because of you wearing headphones?
He has that.
Look at him.
Oh no!
Don't do him like that!
Damn!
A little shimmy?
Alright, alright.
I see you, I see you.
Luto knows how to work the crowd.
Yeah!
Look at that.
Oh my god, wait.
I just realized that's a diaper.
What the fuck did that not promise?
That's a fucking diaper!
I guess demons need diapers.
True.
Never thought about that.
Bro, I can hear myself.
There we go.
Sayu with the Goku hair.
Oh my god.
If Luto is smart, she'd take off the diaper and just yeet it at him as an intimidation tactic.
Oh!
Immediately with a...
Oh my god!
Don't tell me this big demon is a high flyer.
Already starting with the freaking aerial moves.
Yeah!
Holy crap!
Already pinned him.
Oh, he keeps jumping!
Oh, you broke your back!
No!
Oh!
Focus on the arm.
Yeah, clip those wings.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, oh, she's in pain.
Oh, oh, she's gonna come back.
Reversal.
Missed the elbow.
Ooh.
Ooh, and he breaks her top one down.
Oh no.
Sayu targeting the legs here.
Oh, punch her.
You know Kanda Roo's have really strong punches.
I'm not sure if they're so scary.
Woo!
Nice!
Look at that leap.
Are you crazy?
This big demon is a high flyer.
Right?
This fucking maneuvering.
That's terrifying.
Ooh, suplex by Sayu.
Setting foot in the ring now.
Oh, they're going back in the ring.
Sayu being polite, waiting for Luto.
Very nice of him.
To the turnbuckle.
What's going on?
Oh, is she gonna jump on him?
Another aerial!
Oh my god!
No!
500 pounds!
Jesus, his ribs are broken!
On top of the tech support.
I think the diaper added more pounds to it.
Dude, I think so.
Oh god!
Oh jeez.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Wow, that was pretty cool.
Dude.
They're maneuvering so good.
Holy crap!
Come on Sayu, you gotta win for all tech support guys everywhere.
You gotta do it!
From the back!
Yeah, clip those wings.
Yeah!
That's his favorite move.
Get her out!
Oh, and a pin from Sayu.
Ooh!
Nah, not even a one count.
Nah, nah, nah, nah.
Come on, you gotta step it up!
I'm not feeling impressed yet.
Thinks a lot of it for us.
I feel like both of their endurances are really...
really high.
Oh, knee to the face!
Dude, look at that freaking jumping around they're doing.
Ooh.
Oh!
She keeps missing like that.
Oh my god!
Dude, those free aerial kicks just take me out like every time.
It's so brutal.
Oh, right to the gut.
Are you gonna jump?
Another aerial kick!
Oh!
Here we go!
Oh, she gets...
Oh, she gets fucking knocked down!
It's punch to the back.
Submission!
True, true.
That's terrible.
You kinda have to wonder what the heck is in that diaper.
That's true.
It's very, very bloated.
I wanna find out if I'm being honest with you.
I don't wanna know.
What's scary is that the tail also pops out of the diaper.
So...
That's already like a hole in there.
Oh god.
So who knows, maybe there's a...
Maybe there's a signature move with the diaper.
Okay.
Oh!
Oh no, but they got out.
They're fighting it out.
They're fighting outside.
You gotta get in the ring!
Oh man, Sayu's just getting carried away.
What's the count for?
Damn, Sayu taunting.
Ooh.
Doesn't care about the count.
Right to the hamstrings.
Oh, there we go.
Alright, back in the... there they go.
Luto thinking about her life choices.
Taking her time.
She's taking her time.
She doesn't need to rush.
Does she wanna move from Australia to America after this?
Who knows?
Oh my god.
Oh my god, poor Luto.
She's getting beat the fuck up.
Oh my god.
Yeah, being dragged on the floor.
Oh, finisher!
Oh!
No.
It's Sayu's favorite move.
The clip in the wings again.
Oh my god.
Yeah.
You know, if you really kinda think about it, it almost looks like Sayu's kinda wearing a diaper too.
A little bit.
Just a little bit for the back there.
That's a new meta!
That's a new meta for wrestling.
Yeah.
It works for intimidation.
Honestly though, if I saw Luto in the ring, I'd shit my pants too.
Valid.
So valid.
Ooh.
Oh, they're holding hands?
Oh, this is...
Oh, they throw them out.
It was another aerial.
Again!
Oh no, that's scary.
That's scary.
Oh, you're so far away.
Oh!
Whoa!
From the roof!
That leap!
Insane!
Oh my god!
Sat on Sayu's face with that dirty diaper!
Oh!
Not quite, not quite.
Almost.
Oh, rolled out of the ring.
Sayu needed to escape.
Not the miss.
Ooh!
This is actually pretty...
This is intense.
Oh, what's he doing?
He's gonna do the...
He really likes the hands.
Suplex!
Oh!
Is this gonna be a triple suplex?
Woohoohoohoo!
How is he doing that?
Crazy!
That demon is a thousand pounds!
And he's just tech support!
Oh man!
Oh shit, come on, you gotta get up!
Trying to remove, trying to decapitate the demon there.
Oh!
I like how they have the same color scheme.
They can be on one team.
That's true, they got like that hot pink going on.
Yeah, yeah!
Oh my god, literally?
Twenty?
Oh!
Is Sayu gonna be counted out?
No, come on!
You gotta get up!
Nine!
Sayu!
Not like this!
Oh my god!
And Luto wins!
Holy shit!
Luto won that!
Damn!
By knocking Sayu out of the ring.
After she went to get some snacks.
It's Luto!
LUTOOOOOO!
Woo!
Holy crap!
Dude!
I thought Sayu was gonna win.
Oh my god.
Yeah, no, that chest is crazy.
That's really big.
That's what the diaper does!
That's the power of the diaper!
Holy shit!
Yeah, it embiggens the chest.
And makes everything like really, really strong.
Damn!
Wow.
Luto!
With a win!
Well, congratulations, Miss Luto!
I'm gonna be honest, I didn't think someone...
I guess you just look really small in front of me.
I don't know, you look super big in the ring!
Apparently you were seven feet tall!
Yeah!
What do you have to say, Miss Luto?
It's the diaper, man!
And Sayu is standing on a stool?
What are you guys talking about?
I got robbed.
You got robbed?
Sayu, would you like to explain how did you get robbed?
I think that count was a little fast.
It went from eight, then nine, and then ten just came like half a second faster.
I'm just saying.
Also, it's my first day on the job.
Classic.
Classic rig card.
Hey, you know...
Yeah?
Yes?
Yeah.
No, that's it, you know?
It was right there.
We don't!
We don't know.
Just take the L and move on, man!
Just move on.
That's for Luto.
Crazy.
Luto, I must...
The only W is for me, the L for you, man!
Luto, I must ask.
I've been curious.
I'm sure the audience is also very curious.
What was your inspiration for your outfit?
Oh!
I'd like to know that too, actually.
I wanted to be the most, like, flamboyant one.
I wanted to kill you guys with how gay I am.
Whoa!
Oh my god!
The power of...
What was the power of being gay?
I can't believe it.
Sayu has died by gay.
You know what?
A way to go.
Wouldn't have it any other way.
Did you like my diaper?
Did you like it when I sat on your face?
Yeah!
Was it warm, Sayu?
No, I wasn't a fan of the diaper, but everything else was fine.
Everything else was fine.
The diaper, I wasn't a fan.
Oh, we were fans of it, huh?
Okay.
We really liked the diaper.
See, this is why I stick to a desk job.
Oh my goodness!
The match was super close.
You guys went on for a while, and...
I must say, I'm very proud of both of you guys.
Even though someone may have upped their class a little bit because of a diaper.
I think it was a fair fight.
Oh man.
Yeah, I think I only won because of the diaper, to be honest.
If you really think about it, there was a pin, and that's very dangerous on the diapers.
So, if anything, I'm just saying...
Probably, just qualifications could be a thing.
Well, actually, she should have been disqualified.
Well, Sayu, your suit was made out of metal, so I don't know what you want me to do.
No, it just looks that way.
It just looks that way?
Okay.
What is it?
It's just cloth?
It's just very good material.
It's just very good cashmere.
I don't know what you want from me.
Oh yes.
The coat, man.
The coat.
Actually, AI0, Humanity 1.
Humanity 1.
Well, thank you so much.
I am so grateful and honored to have witnessed this match, and I would like to thank you both for wrestling each other.
Thank you.
Congratulations again, Ms. Luto.
Oh yeah.
Let's go!
What's that weird?
Thank you for wrestling each other.
Thank you for smashing and dashing and ball smashing.
What do you want me to say?
Thank you for doing it for Juna.
Thank you.
Yes, I love watching people fight.
I love watching people fight.
Thank you, Luto.
Thank you.
I will sit on you with my diaper again.
Thank you, Juna.
I'd rather you didn't.
But thank you.
Alright.
Now that was all for this fight.
And now we will actually be going back to the main stage.
Because I believe now we will be subbing in the other casters.
I think we're being kicked out for our diaper comment.
I was too far.
Okay.
I'm sorry.
Sorry.
Listen.
Just, I mean, Doki, if you want, you can give me another chance.
Alright, it's fine.
I promise.
I promise!
Thank you to Kai and Octavio for casting the first game!
We have Snuffy and Fillion in the house now!
In the stadium, in the backstage!
And I'm queuing in!
Can we get Snuffy and Fillion on the intercoms for us?
Snuffy and Fillion, are you guys here?
Hello?
Are you guys ready?
We're ready, boss.
Alright, Snuffy, do you know who is next in the match?
Myself.
Yeah!
Shout out to some bows, baby!
And she's against Fuyo.
Yes, yes.
Miss Fuyo.
Now, Fuyo is in the building as well.
How do you feel, Snuffy?
Finally.
How do you feel?
Finally, I get to talk to Fuyo the legend.
We've been saying a couple words back and forth.
Not gonna lie to you, chat.
Why didn't you guys post that on Twitter?
Why didn't you?
I should've!
You should tweet that out right now so the viewer audience will know what...
Anyway, for those who don't know...
Chat, you better make this pop off because it's about to age poorly in 20 minutes.
Yeah, we're talking milk out here.
I need you guys to know, Snuffy and Fuyo were like chit-talking each other in the server.
We're talking milk out here.
Oh, like they were making like elaborate videos and everything to each other, but they never posted it in the public.
I had no idea.
I was like, why he had to just tweet that shit out?
It was fucking personal.
They did like high effort video shit to each other, but it just stayed in the Discord server.
I was so confused.
Anyway, next matchup is with Snuffy versus Fuyo.
And will be casted by Snuffy and Fuyo.
Off to the interview stage.
Oh, the Snuffy.
I did scream a lot yesterday and now my voice is fricked today.
If it cracks, then it is what it is.
Also, Snuffy, did you just use Shadow Clone Jutsu on yourself?
That's actually an actor I've substituted myself in for.
Oh, okay.
You're fighting a Leprechaun reject or what's going on here?
Excuse me, that's Fuyo Man?
That's Fuyo Man.
Fuyo Man smash.
Fuyo Man slaps the wrap horn.
I'm so fucking dead, you guys.
You're dead already, but you haven't even started the fight.
Fuyo Man, Fuyo Man, please, mercy, mercy.
No mercy.
Oh shit.
I didn't know it was going to be like this, dude.
Shit talk.
Yeah, I want to hear some candy versus a heart.
I want to hear some candy versus a heart.
Let's have a made this junk public.
I'm going to be motherfucking Cheerios because I'm about to eat this Leprechaun for breakfast, dude.
Let's go.
You could have done that last night.
But you were too scared to show up.
Snuff, you're going to take that?
Yeah.
Let me just... what do these cards say?
Just call me Daft Punk because tonight I'm going to get lucky.
I'm going to fully like my laundry.
Okay.
I'm over witnessing Twitter in real life right now.
I just want to see them fight.
I just tweeted an aggressive video towards Fuyo Cloverman.
Oh, you're sub tweeting right now?
He told me the same thing.
What is going on?
I can't come up with anything clever so I'm resorting to posting on social media.
That's classic.
Fuyo men will destroy.
Oh god.
Alright, well, Loser has to delete their Twitter.
Can we agree?
Oh.
No.
Yeah, we'll put all the cards on this one.
That's simply the winner.
Well, I...
I'm going to go with the card.
I'm going to go with the Tension and...
I feel one is very, very ready, and the other is a little intimidated.
Slightly.
Ever so slightly, I think.
But I am excited to see how this goes.
I've been waiting since yesterday, but it's finally happening, and I'm sure everyone else is super excited.
Are you ready to fight?
Yes.
It's my grand legacy.
I'm going to win four games in a row.
And Fuyo, you're going to be the first step on the way to victory.
It's your canon event!
I would like to see you troll.
Dang.
Snuffy, how are you gonna commentate yourself?
Don't worry.
This is all a hired actor performance.
This is just on my mini list of things that I'm extra skilled at.
Wait, Snuffy, we swapped seats!
Yesterday I was on the other side.
How sick is that?
My voice is dying one sec.
We bought more than one seat this time.
I like sharing our seat.
Yep, alright, let's have a get in this junk.
Snuffy, what is your... what is your face reveal?
I'm the trash man!
I go out and I start throwing garbage all over the place.
Yeah, you look like you need a gastric bypass.
I don't know if this is gonna work out, Snuffy.
This is Danny Stavito!
This is my hired actor!
He's too paid to win the game for me.
Danny Stavito.
In this corner...
We have...
The little green thing...
Becoming the big green thing!
It's not Fuyo Cloverfield, it's Fuyo Man!
Why is there another diaper?!
I can't deal with this man!
Well, Philly, in wrestling, it does get dirty.
He's also not to have any accidents on the ring.
Are those programmer socks?
What is going on, ladies and gentlemen?
Programmer socks?
You see that junk?
No, those are like, high... like knee highs.
Those are beautiful.
Kind of kinky.
Oh, nice.
A little bit of sugar in his step, dare I say.
Thanks.
A little bit of gold at the end of the rainbow, you know?
Bro's showing us the whole rainbow right now.
They're really doing it to us.
They're showing us his lucky charms.
And finally, risen from her slumber...
Debuting the face reveal, the trash man, Snuffy!
Snuffy, you didn't shave!
What?
It's me, I'm over here!
It's me!
I'm winning!
I'm gonna win it all!
Wait, can you not hear the game sound either, Snuffy?
I'm through, everybody!
It just sounds like you're talking in a room by yourself to me.
Why isn't the crowd going crazy right now, guys?
Come on!
Everybody, woo-yah!
Woo-yah, Snuffy, the trash man!
Woo-yah!
Fucking go!
You're gonna hit the MC hammer!
Who's fucking tweaking right now?
What am I watching right now?
Are you gonna take off the hoodie or just stay on in the fight?
I think I take it off.
I'm really just the same.
Oh, yeah!
You should've just put it back on!
Okay, here we go.
I gotta fucking win this one.
Oh my god.
Okay, we're so not fast with Snuffy, just handing the actual beat down on this man.
Slay head slam to the face.
And this dude is already reeling.
I don't know where Snuffy is.
She's under the table right now?
Am I slow-casting this?
Fuck you!
Fuck you, bitch!
Grab ahold of the arm snap!
Okay.
I'm just gonna go for the straight up arm snap.
Okay, now this is about to be the actual Richter Thor-scale earthquake right now.
Slap!
There's no way to overwave!
One!
Two!
Okay, no, just a one count.
Just a one count.
Snuffy, don't get too ahead of yourself.
You're not gonna get him that effing easy.
But so far, this has been a one-sided beatdown.
I feel like I'm watching, I don't know, like, Michael's son from GTA try and fight Trevor right now.
This is absolutely grim coming out of the effing, uh, the gates here.
I mean...
Okay, straight for the nuts!
I mean, hit him where it hurts!
That's a straight critical.
Mysterio walks!
Snuffy walks back to her corner to give this man some time to breathe, only to come in with a rocket fist face slam.
I mean, this is ridiculous.
This dude's mohawk is painted like a rainbow and his face is gonna be painted red soon.
Wait, it's not the face slam!
Wait, is he getting pinned?!
Wait, Snuffy, you almost got reversed!
Alright.
Looks like this man's trying to take out the trash.
And Snuffy's really...
This man is making a getaway!
Just kidding!
The animation cancelled back into the arena.
Okay, and Snuffy's going for the backbreaker.
Gonna age his spine about a few years.
And now she's tossing out the chair.
And now the chair's gonna take out the trash herself!
I'm gonna eat you like an egg!
This is called hiding the body.
She learned this one from Metal Gear Solid.
And now she's gonna pick him up and maybe...
I don't even know.
Put him back down.
This goes crazier than an Eminem rap song right now.
I'm gonna do my signature move.
A trash scrawl!
Bruh!
Here we go!
You messed up.
Snuffy!
No, no, this is the build up!
Look at that!
Oh yeah, baby!
Oh yeah!
My man is sniffing the rainbow, but the backflip misses and he gets up.
Get a fucking whip!
Oh shi- I feel like Snuffy might be getting rocked here.
She's getting taken out too, again, off the top rope.
I think her spine hit a 45 degree angle, but this man is...
Jesus Christ!
Crushing in her chest cavity right now.
Oh, for you!
For you!
AHHHH!
Wait, Snuffy, you good?
Snuffy, you good?
Oh shi- And both of them decide to make a mutual agreement to take the fight outside of them at the exact same time.
But this man is tenacious.
He stops at nothing.
Oh my god!
I'm in the wrestling match anymore!
This is a brawl in the back streets of Detroit!
Fuck!
Okay, Snuffy's about to take him and throw him back where he came from, sending him out of the arena himself.
Oh god!
They're getting married!
You can kiss the bride!
Just kidding, he's Andrew Tate.
And now he's going back in.
He's gonna pick Snuffy up.
Now we're entering dangerous territory, ladies and gentlemen.
There's an epic six seconds on the clock.
Four more seconds and they're going to be out.
I'm gonna win it!
Oh!
Snuffy, you have to get back in the arena!
Okay, not bad.
Okay, they're back in.
The competitors are back in.
It's almost Monday.
That means it's almost trash day.
I can still win.
Snuffy's getting reset back to default programming right now.
I mean, she might go work at a trash compactor after this job's over.
But she is fighting for the ground tooth and nail.
I'm gonna make food eat all the place she was just in a trash compactor!
Okay.
I'm gonna gouge your eyes out.
Oh, god!
The key!
Oh!
And he's giving her some crazy action right now!
Even crazier action!
Is Snuffy into it?
No, she is not!
No, she's not!
And this man is so frustrated.
He got her number, but he couldn't get to fourth base.
He's gonna taunt her now that she's on the ground.
This is insane.
Oh, yeah!
Let me go!
Oh, my god!
She's getting stepped on.
She's like watching an effing sub in real time.
I'm not talking submarine, ladies and gentlemen.
T-bagged her on the way through.
Picks her up and slams her down the floor!
Oh, my god!
And now this man is hitting an effing...
Hawkeye reindeer?
Okay.
I think Snuffy just might be dead.
I'm not willing to see that call sign anymore.
Her rings are shattered.
What's going on?
She's getting bedspreads!
I mean, I know VTubers are light, but come on, Snuffy!
That dropped like a paperweight!
Holy moly!
Oh, this could be it.
Oh, god!
Is he gonna do a backflip?
He just straight up misses.
You fucking thought!
You thought!
You thought I was dead!
Oh, my god!
And then Snuffy's turned to turn around.
That's why I'm a paid actor, Fuyo man!
That's why I'm a paid actor!
And now I'm gonna make you eat dirt!
I mean, that was a devious elbow straight to his left nipple.
I think that might be an effing sub.
Another one to the left nipple!
We're taking serious damage there.
That's gotta be bruising.
Okay, the third T back of the fight.
He goes in for the single leg shot.
My moment!
Snuffy counters and then tosses him out like trash again.
Sorry.
Oh, my god!
That looked like an illegal nut shot!
He went head over nut!
And he is down on the ground for sure.
I'm just falling on top of you.
I don't have any special moves.
Oh, god!
I'm gonna twist your fucking head!
Snuffy's just gonna break his neck!
I'm gonna rip your ears off!
Some of these moves are getting down by a little bit.
Oh, my god!
Here we go, ladies and gentlemen.
In the ninth- they are busting out all of the moves.
Oh!
And you need to win this crown.
Oh, god, I'm...
Snuffy, you're fleeing the fight right now!
I need a minute.
I need like five seconds.
Just give me like... Oh, my god.
Oh, no.
The green goblin comes in with the effing green neck snap.
Snuffy's down for the count.
But it's a good thing she cannot get pinned outside of the arena.
Otherwise, she might be dead right now.
Oh, my god!
That was my heart!
I think it just exploded.
Oh!
Okay, he just sent her back home.
I'm getting yanked around like a fish.
Snuffy, how are you feeling about the fight so far?
Hell, you have so much endurance!
Wait, the roll is off of the mat!
And she's actually getting pulled around!
Jesus Christ!
Somebody called Dana White!
This is getting outside the scope of a fight.
I mean, I don't even know if Snuffy can get up in time.
We're up to six seconds, ladies and gentlemen.
Give me like two more seconds, maybe.
Seven seconds?
No, one.
Then restart the count.
Oh my god.
I mean, Snuffy's notes have become internal at this point.
You put up any value buttons, but...
There's too many people counting on me right now!
My senpai!
My master!
I won't disappoint them!
I can't!
Not after all the training I went through!
Alright, Izuku, you're up.
Izuku Midoriya is kicking it into gear to take out Bakugo here.
I'm not sure if this is gonna pay off though.
OH!
I'm gonna show everybody my special skill!
She's heading to do the London Bridge's falling down?
I don't know if this man can survive what's happening right now.
I think Snuffy has eighteen different variations of falling on top of him.
And it's somehow working.
Don't you wanna hug Fuyo, man?
Don't be afraid of the dark!
One!
Two!
There's no way!
My god, this was so close!
This was so close!
Snuffy's about to save blood for the Blood God.
Just give up!
The hammer of Elba dropped.
I think Snuffy is saying my order was still raw and she wants a refund on it.
I'm not really sure to take from that one.
Give me my drink!
I think three concussions in this fight, ladies and gentlemen.
And these characters are not really still in at this point.
We're just watching cells of their former selves fight for anything.
I'm gonna make your fucking brain!
A shamrock shake!
Oh!
And Snuffy uses the falling for the eighteenth time!
I mean, Snuffy certainly has a favorite move.
Let's fucking go.
Just call me fucking Fall Guys because you're about to see this guy fall!
And she's effing twerking.
What?
She had a backflip?
There's no
way!
Oh my god!
Oh my god, Fuyo, man!
You have the endurance of a god!
I commend you!
She's gonna commend him with a hearty choke to the neck.
I mean, this is the fight that keeps on giving, chat.
It is like hepatitis.
These fires do not stop for anything.
Come here, man.
Come here.
I'm gonna show you why I take out the garbage.
At some point, I wouldn't be surprised if Snuffy grabbed an audience from the effing stands to pull into this fight.
Use them as a bludgeoning tool.
Oh god!
I mean, this is getting serious business.
I see a kid in the front row.
I mean, I don't know if he can handle that.
Let's see what's happening right now.
They're back into the arena as we speak.
And I think Snuffy...
Oh, she...
Super slam!
This is not like on the tramp.
She'll have a spirit bomb straight on top of her.
Oh, I mean...
Oh, Folio man, are you exhausted?
Oh shit, my balls!
I don't know how these two fires are still standing.
Folio man, stop!
Oh no!
Wait!
There's no way!
He said, Snuffy, do you like that?
You like that?
She does not!
Oh my god.
She's still in this fight.
I don't even know how she's doing.
I don't know how they're still alive.
This random girl in the back is cheering for USA.
I think this man came to the wrong concert venue.
Oh my god.
Because I'm American!
She's a leprechaun!
Could Snuffy take out the luck of the Irish?
No, that guy said, this is awesome, get a life!
Her leg just got kicked through the rope.
I don't even know what's going on.
I just got my toes stubbed.
Oh god!
What's happening?
Folio, please.
Oh!
Oh my god!
Is he going for the pin?
No, another powerbomb.
Never mind.
I don't know what's happening.
The fireman...
A new move, ladies and gentlemen!
Oh my god!
That is a fractured elbow.
And now he's raising the roof like an effing 2018...
I don't know if I can last.
I don't know if you can make it, but the roaring 20s is called.
They want their dance moves back.
This man is about to go and grab the top rope, I imagine.
But he's really far away from Snuffy.
I don't know if he can reach.
Oh my god!
And he turns her head into a pancake.
I mean, her IQ is definitely below 100 if it wasn't before.
Just kidding.
What the frick!
No!
Wait!
Snuffy took her own self out of the move!
Snuffy!
No!
You took yourself out!
What happened?
And our winner...
It usually isn't easy being green, but today, green has won!
It's Fuyo Man!
Fuyo Man!
Yeah.
Holy moly.
Fuyo Man, destroy!
Snuffy!
Snuffy, are you there?
Oh!
Oh god!
I have murdered a raccoon.
Oh yeah, I got...
I just got my shit kicked in so bad.
I got my shit kicked in so bad.
I can almost feel that actor's realism.
He got his shit kicked in so bad, dude.
That was insane.
That was an actual slobber knocker of a fight.
Yo, Mr. Fuyo, did you ever feel like the match was in doubt?
No, this is just an horrible Saturday.
Or Sunday.
I can't get the days right.
But sure can't land his punches.
You gotta respect that, ladies and gentlemen.
Just tell me, Fuyo Man, on a Saturday.
On a Sunday, he's already so unpleasant.
Meet him on a Saturday, you might not even leave to tell about it.
Dang, Fuyo Man, you put up a good fight.
It looks like we settled the beef.
So, uh, Snuffy.
Are you gonna rescind all of your statements you made against Fuyo?
I always knew Fuyo was gonna be my biggest hurdle in the fight, and that's why I don't mind that I lost to them, because I feel like they're gonna go and win it all.
And it'll show that I was truly, at least, second best at the most.
Man.
Alright.
That is okay.
Well...
Those are acceptable standards.
That was a crazy fight.
That was like 18 variations of people turning themselves into pancakes.
I mean, like I'm talking IHOP at that point.
Yeah, that looked like a Waffle House at 3 in the morning.
That was pretty insane.
We had the the sort of energy and stamina that...
I would like to say something.
You'd only see normally in a rabid fight.
So, it looks like Ursula stole our interviewer's voice, and then hopefully she'll return at any second now.
But...
Yeah.
So, anyway, what I was thinking...
I was mad!
Fuyo-man, please, before you go, please!
I must ask!
What?
It's a temperament.
I-I-I'm our first match.
Sudo had a diaper and won!
You had a diaper and won!
What does this mean?
Please!
I must know!
It's a fashion statement.
Bro said belt!
They're reinventing the wrestling attire here by mainstreaming the diaper.
Do you plan on rocking this diaper if you win at all?
What does that say about future wrestling?
The diaper stays on during the match.
Dang!
The World of Warcraft classic drip.
I mean, this person's dynamic and they are full of utility.
God, Sam!
Snuffy, I-I must-I must ask.
Was the person standing in for you did he shower?
No, he never showered.
When I did-when I went through the interview process, he was probably the stinkiest of the bunch.
I was hoping maybe if he didn't have...
Yeah.
Maybe if he didn't have pure fighting skill, he might have just been able to, like, fumigate Fuyo to the point where she would not be able to, like, enter the ring.
It would be like a debuff.
Like a-like a nuclear gas.
I will say I've done my-I've done my research on Fuyo and Fuyo does- Fuyo man, would you like to explain what I'm about to say?
I believe the stench was matched.
Yes.
Wait, your stench maxing?
Fuyo man only showers once a month.
Of course.
My stench didn't bother Fuyo at all because they matched it even with something even stinkier.
Exactly.
I'm gonna be honest.
I think that was the best match of WrestleTuber 2024 yet.
Oh my god!
I-I'm-I'm-I'm gonna be honest.
I think it was the best one.
And I-I can't wait to see how Fuyo-how far Fuyo man goes.
I believe in you, Fuyo man.
Let's go, Fuyo man!
Yeah!
Yay!
Well.
And, um, now I get my co-caster back.
Da-ding!
Yeah, now I don't have to grow in the whole time.
I mean, the paid actor, of course.
That was definitely not me getting my ass peed.
That was not humiliating in the least.
I was also just a paid actor.
Alright.
I believe it's time for our next fight.
Are we gonna bring on our contestants?
Is that how this works?
Wait a second.
Since Fuyo won, does that mean Fuyo sticks around?
Yeah, Fuyo is gonna go fight the next fight now.
I believe Fuyo man is gonna take the whole match.
Wow.
And Fuyo man's- Of course.
And Fuyo man's opponent is going to be none other than the lovely Nana?
Yes.
The Nana that destroyed the Gerard, the pregnant dinosaur.
Oh.
Alright, well I can't wait to see when she, uh, when she shows up on the effing set, but, uh, Fuyo!
I mean, are you gonna change up your strategy this time around versus Snuffy?
Fuyo man destroy.
Miku?
Tatsune Miku?
Good morning.
Good Miku morning.
Miku morning!
Miss Nana, are you ready to fight the Fuyo man?
Oh yeah!
Let's go!
I have a habit of crushing small things on the earth.
You're calling Fuyo man small?!
Oh yeah!
Compared to the galaxy, all I see is a tiny green snotty speck.
Oh!
Frig!
Fuyo man destroy.
Someone just casted Shrigger onto Fuyo man.
I mean, this is more accurate champ size right now.
This is ridiculous.
Fuyo man big heart.
Fuyo- yes, Fuyo man, you're very, very big.
So large.
They shrunk down to save their energy.
Yes.
I see, I see.
I think honestly the biggest thing here is Fuyo man's ego, which I'm about to crush tonight.
Dang!
I think that's a good assumption.
I think if Fuyo man continues this match, by the time he's done with his last match, he's gonna Dr. Manhattan fucking delete the next guy.
So you need to put a stop to this.
Like a god dang super villain.
Leave it to me!
Do you feel the pressure?
I have history.
I have a complete resume of putting an end to many things, including bloodlines.
So watch out for your man.
Dang!
I mean, speaking of superheroes, you guys are pretty much the same size as Thanos and Ant-Man, and we all saw that day we could end up.
So, any predictions today, chat?
Let's see.
I think they're ready.
Fuyo man destroy.
The viewers are rooting for Nana today.
Fuyo man is close.
They want to see Fuyo man win it all, but they also would like to see Nana bring in a win, it looks like.
Fuyo man, I have the ultimate question for you, Fuyo man.
New York or DC?
Europe.
Doesn't matter.
Doesn't matter because I will be sending your dead leprechaun corpse to the National Museum.
Anywhere.
Okay?
That's where I'll be sending it.
Oh my god.
He's gonna be a specimen in the museum.
Don't even ask for a mailing address.
Just send her a coffin.
She's come to deal business.
Oh yeah.
You will need all the leprechaun work for that.
We need all the leprechaun work for that.
Oh yeah.
You're talking up the luckiest person in the room right now.
That's pretty hard.
I'll take my chances.
Fuyo can win out of pure luck.
She's got that manipulation going.
She's got the plus 10 luck skill.
That's a pretty insane logic.
Anything can be your downfall.
You might trip on a banana peel.
Why is there one in the wrestling room?
Luck baby, luck.
Life is a gamble.
Bring it on.
I think that's the great attitude to bring it on.
I would like to see this match.
Fuyo versus Nana.
Nana?
This is gonna be good.
Wait.
Now you got me doubting.
It's Nana, right?
Or Nana?
It's Nana.
Okay.
Thank you.
Banana ooh nana.
There is a banana on the stage.
Ooh nana.
I've never heard that.
Wait.
Can I not hear the... Okay.
Ooh.
I like the fit.
It's giving Rarity My Little Pony very amazing personal favor.
Stop.
That's literally what Juna told me.
That's literally what Juna...
I'm sorry.
All the way from the cosmos of Australia.
I like the halo.
You know them as the vanquisher of dinosaurs.
It's the galaxy.
It's Nana.
Give me some audio on the TV.
Yeah.
Not Doug who can't hear it.
Whoa.
Okay.
An angel ascends down from the heavens.
I mean this is absolutely magnificent.
Oh my.
The drip is insane.
This might be one of my favorite wrestling outfits I've yet to see.
Oh my God.
And she wastes no time getting straight into the arena.
Krong on all fours like a possessed animal.
But this is not an animal.
She's displaying her absolute attitude and ownership of this stage.
There's at least 10 Discord moderators saying please step on me right now.
I can tell.
I'm one of them and I'm currently in her DMs.
Interesting.
Well we're gonna have to see if...
He's mean.
He's green.
It's the diaper wearing machine coming back.
FUYA MAN!
I just had shivers go down my spine.
Yeah the PTSD kicked in.
I think...
Oh my God.
The way he looked.
I hate the way you look.
The way you talk.
This mean green killing machine has already shed some blood today.
Will they be back to return that favor?
Will they still have the stamina to take another win?
Will they show you guys why I died?
And it wasn't because I'm unskilled.
Truly.
We're gonna see why.
Nana will put up a good fight I'm sure.
We might be able to see Nana pull off a win here.
Nana's tired.
Yeah that's what I was gonna say right?
Fuyo Man just came out of an epic grueling fight.
Do you see his chest?
It's red and sore.
I think it's just his nips slipping I'm not gonna lie.
Insane pepperonis there.
With eyes.
They also have eyes I see.
I'm not sure what the context is but alright let's go.
Straight into the fight!
Nana taking an instant lead on this.
Oh!
Nana is taking control of the situation.
She's lifting for...
Oh my god!
A little bit...
Fuyo takes advantage of that sloppy landing.
Nana might have gotten ahead of herself here.
Oh no!
Is it gonna be a clothesline?
No it's a collision head on.
40 miles an hour train versus 40 miles an hour train.
That's a massive problem.
Nana taking control of the situation with an amazing dead drop there.
Oh!
And just mind gaming the situation here.
Whoa!
She just pulled Fuyo's signature move on himself.
She jumped over his head with a tea bag.
I mean that's a taste of his own medicine.
Oh!
She's grabbing him by the beard.
Whoa!
Bringing Fuyo man down to the ground.
Oh!
Fuyo man's got it with a straight kick!
Kicks from the floor as well as beard grabbing.
I mean this fight is already off to an unkempt start.
Fuyo.
Oh my god!
Really showing those bar fights coming in handy here.
Oh my goodness!
Going for the weak spots right on the elbow there.
That's gonna throw her in the air.
That's gonna throw Nana in for a turn anytime they want to set up some moves.
Oh!
Pull up!
I mean, Nana's kind of taking that beating roll into this fight.
Oh my goodness!
Yeah!
Fuyo man is leading quite strongly into this match.
Oh!
But Nana is turning the moves back around in her favor.
This could still look up to her.
Oh!
She got on the beard again!
Leave the man's face alone!
She's insane!
Remove the flesh and bone!
Go Nana!
Go!
Do what your body is telling you!
Remove the flesh!
Oh sorry I got a little bit of a...
I'm a little caught up in the moment.
She should have called him Popo but I don't think she needs that guy at this point.
She is just delivering the smackdown on all levels right now.
Oh!
But Fuyo interjects with another low blow.
Elbow to the eyes there.
That's a little...
She's gonna rest and sleep on him.
Nana is showing skill.
Oh my... Fuyo with another low blow.
See Fuyo is just interjecting with these quick little jabs.
And Nana will turn it back around and be like, You know what?
This is what real skill looks like.
Let's see if she can do it again.
Oh and see another situation where a trained professional meets somebody who's only learned through backyard brawling.
Yeah I think Nana has a lot of openings in her defenses.
She keeps getting kicked in the head.
She might have to look out for that weak spot.
Nana has some professionalism.
She looks like she's here to win.
Wait one...
Oh!
Fuyo-man is not so quick to give up as we've seen with our match.
Fuyo-man is a dedicated insane stamina giver.
Oh my god.
But you know I didn't realize...
Oh my god!
The reverse flying axe kick!
Fuyo-man took off the diaper for this match.
This person watches Naruto.
So could this be the loss?
Is this loss?
I don't know.
I think you just take her to Ibiza.
I've seen Warheads slam into the sides of this ring that I've had my entire career so far.
But she's getting picked back up.
And she's stunned.
What is happening?
She just dislocated Nana's arm.
She's being sacrificed like Abraham's eldest son.
Her neck is about to snap.
Fuyo doesn't look like...
Oh she can hold her!
Oh she takes him off.
They're both hurt from that move.
Nana turned that around in her favor.
A weak drop.
She misses her kick there.
Both of these wrestlers behaving like they're at least six drinks in right now.
Not even sure if they know who they're fighting anymore at this point.
Fuyo definitely has at least three concussions.
Oh my god.
Fuyo cannot...
Burping him like a baby boy.
Let's see if Nana can keep the lead.
Fuyo can turn it around.
What is this?
Oh my god.
She got him in the ham sandwich.
They turned into an ice cream sandwich for that maneuver.
Again, Nana really does not have good defense when she goes for grapples.
It's a common weak spot for her.
Wait, she's down!
Fuyo just turned that around on her too.
Oh my...
Fuyo wins just like that!
An instant turnaround.
Fuyo man sweep.
Nana must be green with Evie.
Because moving on is Fuyo man!
It's the second final row, Snuffy!
We witnessed Fuyo Man do a reversal on one of the opponent's signature moves to take them out.
He is a counter-god!
I knew Fuyo Man was going to take the lead and win it all.
I told you guys that his win would be ominous.
Fillion, are you going to step in here?
Will you be seeing Fuyo Man in your matches?
I might have to at this rate.
I'm kind of scared though.
I mean this guy might have a contract with FaZe Clan because this dude can counter strike for sure.
I don't know.
Don't laugh at that.
Okay, let's take it back to the casters or the interviewers.
Oh my god.
Small but mighty.
And strong enough to take down a fucking galaxy?
Nana, what do you have to say?
You were talking big mad shit.
Do you know what?
I'm actually not too mad because guess what?
Fuyo has to go against at least three other people from my dead agency.
And so the will of the Treadmill continues.
I may fall today, but you will go against all those who come after me.
Good luck, Fuyo man.
You are literally invoking all nine members of the One For All legacy right now.
I don't know what's going on.
The F4Legacy is going to be the one for all.
I'm going to be the one for all.
Fuyo is on our head.
What is going on, ladies and gentlemen?
This man has jumped into our hair.
Fuyo man, destroy.
No!
Fuyo man, are you ready to reenact the fucking Christmas Carol?
Because you're about to Ebenezer Scrooge this company's last members.
Are you ready to win it all?
Are you going to fight the ghosts of VTuber past, present, and future?
I will murder.
I see.
He has learned well.
That was a victory with no diaper.
I would like to put that out there too.
Fuyo man did not wear his signature diaper that match.
That means that wasn't even a fraction of his power.
Kindness is cool, Pencil.
Kindness is very cool.
That is actually Fuyo man's real underwear, by the way.
It's true.
Yes, I acknowledge your drip.
Will you be selling it after this match, Fuyo man?
Oh!
If money horrid.
Get your licensed merchandise.
I need an adult!
Fuyo man.
Fundies.
You'll win every match you ever enter.
Oh, I got an SD card.
Oh!
Oh my.
Fillion is dead.
Oh my god.
Fillion is back.
We're so back.
And we'll come back.
Oh my god.
One second.
You don't want to have me now.
Well...
Not an axe like Thanos, snap the wrong person.
Okay, please, I have a right on God's green herb to walk around.
Fireman, what are your next opponent?
It's a bit scary.
Are you ready to raid her dungeon?
Yes.
Fireman raid.
Fireman destroy.
Come on, Omiya Emma, you have to avenge me!
You have to avenge me!
For Prism and for Cerulea!
For all of us!
Stop the leprechaun!
Stop the Irish!
End them!
End quote.
Let's fucking go, Fuyo man.
Your life ends ten seconds from now.
Let's see if that's true.
My final message...
Alright, well we're gonna go ahead and move Nonna out of here.
Thank you so much for competing.
Thank you so much Snuffy and Fillion and Doki.
Great job.
And thank you so much, Fuyo and Juna.
Thank you so much.
Bye bye!
Goodbye, bye bye!
Alright, and we're gonna bring in our next competitor.
Somehow she looks even bigger right now than the other one.
It is going...
I mean, dang!
I mean, bigger in a lot of ways.
She is up and she is ready for combat.
It is...
Emma!
Miss Emma.
Oh.
What?
Is she asleep?
Ring-a-ding-ding, Emma!
Your match is starting!
Oh my god!
Who's there to disturb my sl- What?
What?
Where is the next opener?
Sorry, what's here?
Wiki wiki, Emma!
Emma, it's time for you to call for someone.
Are you ready for this challenge?
I know you just woke up.
I see no one over here.
Are you ready to kill somebody?
Somebody?
Where?
Yo, Fuyo, speak up!
Fuyo, speak up!
You might have to squint a little bit, but Fuyo-man...
Fuyo-man destroyed.
Holy shit!
What is that thing?
Oh my god!
Miss Emma.
Oh, you...
What?
Miss Emma, Fuyo-man has won two games in... two matches in a row.
Do you feel intimidated?
I don't know.
I cannot even see him down there.
Can you climb, Fuyo-man?
Of course.
What is it?
Attack on Titan?
Climb to...
What is happening?
Fuyo-man is not the only thing that can climb on those ropes in the match.
There's other things that Fuyo-man has sealed it, escalating.
Fuyo-man escalated the funny questions.
Wow, Fuyo-man, you are so bold.
I respect that.
Emma, does Fuyo-man feel good?
Fuyo-man feels very good.
Oh, that's very nice.
Three inches.
Fuyo-man, since you are so small, I'm going to smash you like really gentle, okay?
So I'll make sure you don't cry and pee in your diapers.
I'm feeling some weird tension already.
Fuyo-man, destroy.
Okay, Fuyo-man, we shall see about that.
Emma, are you trying to like warm into submission before the match even starts right now?
Because it seems like the charm isn't working right now.
Mind games is exactly what sets the mental for victory.
I am not.
Yeah, and this guy has a stronger mental game than Michael Scott.
I don't know.
Mentally quiver and shake is exactly what you need to make them waver their faulty strength and confidence.
Make Fuyo-man doubt why he's on this stage.
Make him doubt why he was ever in this career.
Fuyo-man is confused.
Oh, no, it's working.
We're manipulating him.
Fuyo-man, you always wanted to be a doctor.
Remember what your mother said.
What does that mean?
Doctor.
Good gaslight.
Yes.
That's amazing.
Well, Fuyo-man is about to perform an elaborate examination on his opponent, Emma, today.
Emma, are you ready for your examination?
I am super ready.
He can inspect me whenever he wants.
I see what he finds.
Sounds like we should get to it.
Oh.
I'm gonna be knowledgable for following you nearly ten or so times.
frick.
Alright.
These two fighters are coming up.
We're gonna see how this goes.
Dude.
I feel like his opponents just keep getting bigger and bigger and bigger.
First was Snuffy.
And she's like a normal-sized kind of human, right?
Right?
And then after that, Nana.
And now a little like... I don't know how many more times this guy can take down.
People come in many different shapes and sizes.
You're barely tall enough to get above the casting fence.
In this corner, winning back to back.
He's mean.
He's green.
You know him.
It's Fuyo Man!
For the third time, this man comes out spinning in circles and hitting poses.
Is he going to take a dump?
And there it is.
And now he's ready for combat.
Oh my goodness.
He makes the crowd quiver.
Everybody's at unease.
They don't know whether to root, cheer, cry, celebrate, text their loved ones.
They don't know what's going to happen.
But Fuyo Man is going to make it freaking happen.
He's going to be legendary.
I just want to see what's under the hat at this point.
I'm really curious.
What's he got underneath there?
The man, the myth, the legend, the leprechaun, Fuyo Man taking the stage, showing off why he is now a two consecutive win winner and perhaps maybe even three today.
And returning all the way from her dungeon, it's your final boss.
But will it be Fuyo Man's final boss?
It's...
Wow.
She comes out with Majestia's Frick.
She looks like the final boss of an Elden Ring franchise game.
She's intimidating.
Lady royalty herself, Emma, about to show what this doctor's appointment will diagnose us with.
Absolute queenship here.
Look at that form.
Look at the professionalism.
Look at the posture.
This bitch is here to win.
Her jewelry kind of looks like a collection of weapons.
I'm going to go with the one that's going to be the most popular.
I don't know if she's gonna be allowed to keep those on during the fight, but hey, I mean, they make custom rules themselves, so we'll see how this goes down.
Oh, she's... she's above getting on the ring herself.
You will... you will let her in.
You will be appropriate here.
You will let a lady into the ring.
No one's going to have her on the ropes.
Chivalry is dead.
All right, slay the crown.
Oh, my God, she's working the crowd right now.
Someone in the crowd just passed out.
Oh, yes.
Take her crown.
Take her throne.
Oh, Fuyo!
Come on, it's Dexter!
I mean, this inspection is his fist with her face, but she kicks him in the nuts, so she knows a thing or two about anatomy also.
And she just slam-dogs him!
I think the fight's over.
Never mind, this man gets up.
How is this possible?
Emma has been watching Fuyo-man's last matches.
She might be able to know how to mind game Fuyo-man to a win here.
She's studied his moves.
She knows his routine.
Ooh, but that might not be enough!
She's reversing the karma on her, disrespecting her at her own game.
Fuyo-man knows a thing or two about psychic damage himself.
Fuyo-man is at the top of his game right now, and he's showing why he is, right now, ready.
He's the next Axel Tuber 2024's prodigal son.
I mean, yeah, this guy's on that thing CSI Miami's most wanted right now.
Oh my god!
Wait, not the rope!
He just clipped her skull through three different layers of rope!
I mean, that's gotta be some quantum physics involvement right there.
This man is breaking rods.
He almost just shattered the game devs' fabrication of this level.
I was worried the whole game was in a crouch, but this guy's getting mounted and beaten to a pulp.
Oh my god!
I mean, he's doing the Omni-Man versus Invincible.
He's doing 40 years speech right now.
Jesus Christ!
He's getting flipped over?
Stared at?
I... okay?
Getting ridden like a piggy bank?
I don't really know.
Uh... oh, he got a jump!
Yana's starting it off strong.
She's not even letting Fuyo-man have a chance here.
Oh!
But Fuyo-man is signature with the jabs.
You know that's his trick move.
Whenever someone gets on top, he finds a way to get out.
He knows, yeah!
Whether it's the knee, the foot, or the elbow, he's always quick with the jabs.
He counters.
And now he's cranking the hog.
He's doing this one for the fans.
That's for sure.
And Nana's gonna get back up and see if she can handle this.
I didn't think she'd roll.
He's getting pinned!
My man got epic scorpion, but it wasn't even close.
Not even for a second.
I mean, wrestling.
This is looking more like a cuddle match at this point.
Can we see a little bit more aggression?
Oh my goodness.
Stop kissing in the bedroom and telling.
I wanna see some bloodshed.
I wanna see some bones breaking.
Fuyo-man, destroy!
Stands her back up.
Puts her down.
He's going for the elbow shatter.
That's a really strong move.
It can break a ligament, I think.
I don't know.
Oh yeah.
Ooh!
Fuyo-man aims to put every single opponent down for the count.
He does not want to see them at work tomorrow.
He wants them to be calling off.
He knew she was leaving the arena, and he caught her out.
Oh my god!
Fuyo-man countering every move Emma throws out.
That's insane.
And just gets slammed over the stairs.
And she's back in the arena.
I think she's hoping for a timeout.
Fuyo-man...
I mean, there's only three seconds.
...gives his composure together.
One second.
Give Emma a little bit of time to...
Okay, and there he goes.
Yep.
His composure fully filled now.
And instantly slamming her head into the ring.
Okay.
Ooh!
But Fuyo-man can't get ahead of himself.
She's no setback.
Let's go!
Let's see.
Ooh!
Oh no!
It's a counter again!
Always quick with the counter.
Damn!
Oh my goodness!
And he's not letting her go.
The crotch grab.
She can care like a pussy, Buzz Lightyear fan.
Oh my god.
Donald Trump can take a page out of this one.
But he's going for the pin right now.
Whoa!
Another quick Fuyo!
Oh my god.
Not quite.
I thought he made quick business and jam out of her.
Just like the last match.
But no.
Emma's gonna show us what she's made out of.
Is he going for the teabag?
Hopefully crunchy peanut butter.
Oh no!
It could be jam.
And Fuyo-man spreading it on his toast for breakfast.
The whiplash slingshot.
She's dazed.
I don't understand how much...
Oh!
Oh my god.
She's got abducted in reverse.
And she's getting picked up.
Pause on the ground.
Is it gonna be a pin?
No, it's gonna be a curve saw maneuver.
She flies across the room with a Superman punch!
Is that lights out?
One, two!
Fuyo-man!
Oh my god.
She was one second away from putting down Fuyo's reign of terror.
And now she's staring at him.
Fuyo-man is a survivor.
Okay.
She might show bruising blood.
But he...
Oh my god.
He's quivering.
He's shaking.
He's begging.
If this goes on for much longer, he might tap out.
But not quite.
The fight still goes on.
Dude, that could have been a serious timeout.
Okay.
And she landed this.
And she tried to put her pits up to the nose.
But Fuyo-man said he smelled worse.
Oh my god.
She just dropped her entire body weight on him.
And she's gonna do it again.
She said, take a whiff of this.
Oh my...
Woo!
Oh, she didn't...
She didn't...
She spared him.
She just skipped over him.
Okay.
Oh!
Oh my god.
And Fuyo is just...
She's showing why you don't skip.
Oh my god.
I feel like I'm watching a John Wick movie right now with the amount of exchanges that are taking place right here.
Oh my...
Oh my god!
What was that?
She just did some sort of Tekken move on him.
That was insane.
That was a Wily Lee's Sun Kick, I believe.
Um, I saw that one in Naruto.
And this man climbs up on the poles just to get beaten down by her even more.
Just can you remember versus her?
She's about to snap her in half again like a Twinkie.
I...
Will he get the move off completely?
He's not sure if he can get the footing here.
Can he make it off?
What's Emma doing?
Nana's fighting back for sure.
What's happening?
Oh my god, just tiring her out?
What was that?
I don't know.
Stretching her body like a masseuse?
I mean, this dude's performing like a sumo wrestler right now.
Fuyo man is wanting Emma to beg for forgiveness.
Oh, and he's not done yet.
He's about to...
Oh no.
Oh no, the Fuyo signature.
Emma's in a pin!
She's in a pin!
One, two, Emma fight!
Oh no, no, no.
It could have ended right there.
That was so close.
But Emma seems to be freeing the arena again.
She's pulling herself on the outside of the wires.
If she gets punched here, she could fall off.
The reversal!
She counters him in his own game!
One!
Could it be?
Two!
No!
Fuyo man is not a quitter!
I mean, every single count goes to at least two nowadays.
It's only going to take one moment from the hit of three count at this point.
They're both...
Yeah, they're both on the ropes here.
This is...
This is getting close.
Literally.
Oh wait, that's the whole point of the thing.
But they're going to go in and snap his ankle!
I don't even know what happened.
I think like, it seems like he is feeling it.
Emma has definitely done some damage here.
I think he might have crippled him.
Oh my goodness.
Oh!
She shoots high on the head kick!
But apparently it was so intimidating, Fuyo falls over anyway.
I believe in Emma.
She's got some fierce kicks.
And those shoes don't look comfortable to get hit by.
She's grabbing Fuyo man.
This could be it.
Fuyo man cannot be hit by Emma's kick.
Emma does not counter this.
There's no cheap shots here.
Oh!
And she's making it so Emma knows now what Fuyo man's game is.
She knows how to win.
She knows not to give Fuyo the upper hand by getting a counter option here.
Let's see if she can win it here.
The chiropractic spinal repair just came out of her.
Now she's doing another chiropractic move.
I mean this guy's getting adjusted from the inside out.
Somebody get Fuyo man's physician on the phone.
Oh!
And he's still in the match!
Oh my god!
Holy moly.
And now Fuyo man's running for his own life.
It might be his turn to flee out of the arena for once.
But I mean he gets a good hit on Emma.
Flip throw.
Oh my god!
I saw bread!
I saw blood!
I think this might be it ladies and gentlemen.
Emma might be out.
One, two, three!
Fuyo man wins three times in a row!
Fuyo man cannot be stopped!
Back to back to back!
Your winner!
Kindness is cool.
I think Fuyo man is a great leader to take this match.
Fuyo man making insane waves here right now.
Three back to back to back sweeps here.
Fuyo man is on fire and does not look like they're letting up at any point.
Who can stop Fuyo man?
Who can take the win?
Yeah.
So I mean some people out there they say Ronaldo's a goat.
Some people say Messi.
But to me Fuyo's my goat.
I'm not gonna lie.
I mean this man has been on an absolute rampage.
He's just torn through three people.
I don't know faster than like geez an effing bull in a china shop.
I mean this man is a force of nature.
Let's bring it back over I think in a little bit to see how this post game breaks down.
Fuyo man sweeeep.
Holy shit.
Emma how are you feeling after that match?
No way.
This can't be.
I lost to a little guy called Fuyo man.
I wasn't supposed to be this easily defeated.
But he's too powerful maybe because he's too green.
I can never defeat a green guy.
That's it!
Dungeon raid is closed!
No one can come in anymore!
I'm gonna go take my rest, gonna respawn, gonna go to chiropractic and everything.
Gonna enjoy the nature.
But I'm gonna be afraid of green.
No, I'm gonna stay at home.
I'm gonna cry.
I hate green.
Green is horrible.
Yo man, your response?
Kindness is cool.
Green is cool.
Throw them and destroy.
I must say, Emma, how did it feel having this tiny little three-incher all over you?
A what?
Hail it up and you're next.
Fuyo is more Santa than Dwayne the Rock Johnson and he's winning just as much.
This is crazy.
Emma, don't be afraid to eat your greens.
Spinach might make your match a win next time.
Don't worry.
Fuyo man is a legend though and I'm excited to see you win.
I'm excited to see what more he conquers in this WrestleTuber 24.
Whoa.
Vegetables are horrible.
Just like Fuyo man.
It's okay Fuyo man.
I wish you suffer eating vegetables forever.
Eat your veggies.
No, Fuyo man.
I will take my rest.
Dungeon raid will be closed for a week, for a month, for a year, for decades.
Fuyo man is banned in my dungeon.
No more Fuyo man.
Dang.
Fuyo man understands.
Fuyo man.
How does it feel being one of the first finalists for the WrestleTuber?
A normal Sunday.
Wow, I love that confidence.
I guess Emma loves a man with confidence.
No wonder she folded.
He is very confident.
Even though it's the intercise.
Alright, well...
Wait, so what do we have coming up next?
Are we...
We have...
It looks like our next match I think is with...
Is this Luto again?
Luto running it back.
I'm not sure who his opponent is today.
Let me see.
Let me check.
Check the broadcast.
We're getting word that it is Luto versus Anon.
Anon?
Who is Anon?
Anon.
Ooh.
They look mighty saucy though.
This is gonna be a good match.
Fuyoman finally getting a well-deserved rest after a three back-to-back win here.
We might see more wins from Fuyoman, but for now...
we're starting it up with a different match today.
We have...
Luto versus...
Anon.
Anon?
I believe it's Anon.
We'll have to ask them what their preferred pronouns are.
We'll find out here.
Dang!
What is this, Luto?
Luto, you are way too dressed up to be fighting someone to the death right now.
I mean, you look extravagant.
Oh, yes.
Oh, what's that?
Wait, hold on.
What?
Okay, that was Anon, I believe.
Sorry.
Anon?
Yes?
Oh, my bad.
I got too excited.
Wait a second.
Who are you?
I'm not.
You impersonated someone?
A master of impersonation.
No, no, no.
I would never.
Interesting.
All right.
And we have also here Luto.
Yes.
Luto, welcome back.
Welcome back.
So, what are your records so far in the tournament, guys?
How have you guys done so far?
Is it like one and one?
I believe Luto maybe has won... has won one.
I believe Luto maybe has won one.
Has won two?
Luto, is it true?
Two.
One or two?
One.
One?
Okay.
We got the one.
Yeah.
Both are at one win.
So, this is a pretty interesting match.
We'll see who's truly stronger here then to win two matches rather than one.
Were you just lucky or is this a true test of skill?
Let's find out.
Well, how are you feeling?
I just want to say, Sao Sao Hall wrestlers, Shenzai Wario, being chilling.
Okay, I'm not.
I cannot lose.
Oh, my God.
I cannot fucking lose you.
A brawl is forming.
Oh, I'm trying to Spirit Bomb right now.
I mean, God power anime and China on her side.
I'm trying.
I better see you beat me hard then, Luto.
If you dare.
I'm gonna sit on you with my stinky guy, but you ain't gonna see.
Do it.
I dare you.
Do it and also choke me while you're at it.
Okay.
Fuck yeah.
I'm so bad.
Oh, God.
You guys are all diaper abusers.
This might be a fight to remember, chat.
Our talent here, they are fierce.
They are fire and they are ripping each other apart in the backstage right now.
What will that say about the match?
Oh, I'm excited.
How are you?
Dude, I want to see them murder each other.
I will murder her right with my ass.
Oh, yes.
Wait, can you bring in a weapon too?
Not me.
I have my tail.
Is that good enough?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Hit me with that too.
Okay, I got you.
I got you.
Oh, thank you.
I mean, no thank you.
That's... that'd be awful.
Actually, I wouldn't want that.
I also don't want to hold hands with you in bed and gloveless.
Will you not change the title of this stream?
Wrestling on Sex.
All right, all right.
I'm gonna go.
I can do that.
Thank you Gamer South for sponsoring today's stream.
Make sure to use code SNACKER for 10% off at the discount section.
Whoa.
That was fun.
Let's get to the fight.
Let's go.
All right, Snuffy.
Here it is.
We got someone that looks like a crash test dummy versus the third one.
I'm not even sure who's gonna win at this point.
I could not tell you which one is which.
Now let's see them kill each other.
True.
I believe none is gonna be the one with the bunny ears, but let's see it.
In this corner, it's the diaper from hell.
The spawn of the demon lord himself, the Crimson Devil.
Hey!
It's LUTO!
Absolutely extravagant.
This guy's just Fuyo, but on a whole different level of zesty.
I mean, this person's coming in for the effing crown.
It looks like they got their horns from a CSGO loot crate.
I mean, there's a lot of effing bling bling on this bad boy.
You know, I almost want to see it.
I feel like somebody, this is somebody who truly rivals Fuyo Man's energy.
And I think if anybody was to bring Fuyo Man's energy, a decent match, it could be Luto.
Luto might be able to match the swagger of Fuyo Man.
But we will see if Luto has what it takes to win it all and see him in the ring.
Or will Luto collapse and we'll see another hero rise to the occasion in the form of NAN.
Why is Luto wearing a coffee filter around her neck?
I believe that's an old Victorian tissue for sneezing into.
See?
Okay.
He just did a really epic strategy.
Just like...
And then you just look upwards.
And it just absorbs the entire radius of the explosion.
So they can wipe the blood off on it.
I see.
It's similar to the diaper.
Yeah.
It's basically Luto is going for a full Versile equipment standard here.
And making their way to the stage.
All the way from Wonderland.
Hopping into the ring.
It's NANANA.
Dang.
I don't know what's going on.
But this is like a nothing Yu Ji Ha clan member.
The outfit.
NAN is giving us a bit of sauce here.
I like the face on the ass.
Very iconic.
She said, I know where you're looking and meet my gaze.
Oh yeah, we're making eye contact right now.
She's kinda like my grandma.
She probably smells like her too.
I imagined at least like death.
Now...
Ooh.
A little bit of sauce.
NAN is looking pretty confident coming into this fight.
I'd like to see her stir it up.
She's got one win under her belt.
So this is not new to her.
I do like the purple gas that's everywhere.
It makes a little bit more mysterious and maybe even smells like peppermint.
But we'll see.
Whoa.
She might be a rabbit, but she's behaving rather catty.
Okay.
Let's see how this fight unfolds.
I don't know what to respond.
Wait.
What's getting started?
Lutoh's just keepin' on the claws.
You see that chunk?
I'm back on.
It is.
I mean these people kind of look like Five Nights at Freddy's characters.
But they are already delivering the animatronic beat down.
Oh my god!
Lutoh might be dressed like a Walmart children's bicycle.
But she is delivering like a semi truck.
Absolutely.
And I thought like at the first like, Nan was going to be in serious danger because of the size difference.
But I mean, Nan knows her angles and she's already doing some big damage on Ludo's extremities.
I mean, she might take down her weak point one by one like Johnny Appleseed cutting down a tree.
Oh, my God.
It's a brains over brawn type situation here, I think, Philly.
And oh, my gosh, Nan might be smaller, but she outsizes by speed and swiftness with this skill.
Oh, my goodness.
She's already got him wrapped up.
Pin!
Two!
Oh!
There's no way.
Two counts of Zoe would have been insane, but Ludo's already fleeing the arena and Nan wants none of it.
This person will stop at the end of the Earth to kill you.
Oh, my God!
A little front flip.
Oh!
I think her face is caved in.
I don't know.
Ludo does have the diaper, so if she shits the bed early, it is going to be able to save her.
That could be the play.
I guess we'll have to see.
And Nan is taunting at the crowd.
No!
Oh, my God!
She got headbutted by the Hordes.
Nan is feeling confident.
And she got the Hordes.
She played with the Bull and she got the Hordes.
They're having to stare down the sentry.
Nan disrespectfully gets back into the arena right in front of Ludo.
Doesn't give a single frick in the world.
Alpha Gigantat energy coming out of her.
And we're going up on a Tuesday.
Nan is keeping the segue of this fight strong in her favor.
Jesus!
Ooh!
And I say that right as she loses her cool.
The Rockstar Splash!
The Whitsplam!
Oh, my God!
Ludo going for it!
Ooh!
How many apps can they take up beating this much?
Ludo is treating Nan like a game of hopscotch.
Oh, my...
Oh!
She won't just stop fucking jumping!
I mean, she does know her weight is her greatest asset, it looks like, in this fight.
Oh!
And Nan is getting the actual beatdown put on her.
Underneath.
Over the top.
Uh-oh!
Picked up.
And...
Oh!
She's breaking her ankle falling down on top of her.
Oh, my God!
Weapons out of nowhere stroking the pin!
Ludo getting the steam into a swift...
Ooh!
I mean, Nan might be indestructible.
They're small and dense.
It's like an effing black hole.
Not just one, but it gets to the second count.
She's still raring and ready to go!
Let's see what she has to show!
In the board!
Right into the crowd!
Oh!
A little bit of fan service for the people!
The guy in the picture!
Definitely got a full head of hair there.
Oh, my God!
Maybe even a kiss!
Ooh!
And some blood on your pants!
Oh, my God!
The joker flip on the ankle.
That was kind of insane.
But it looks like that was a reversal exaggert that Ludo needed.
Just kidding.
These two are getting dirty with it!
Okay!
I've never seen the maneuver in my life!
This man's being pulled in 18 different directions!
I'm like watching human origami right now!
Oh, my God!
She's got her strangled right now!
Absolutely!
But she's plunging her in the face!
Oh, she's got her in the eyes!
We're at six seconds.
Can she get back in the arena?
They're using every possible resource to stay alive this match.
If Nani gets back in, it could be over.
Oh!
And Ludo is getting high off the crowd's energy!
Let's go!
Ludo definitely just formed a clip.
Oh!
And the energy is fueling Ludo like a battery!
She's like a vampire sapping after the energy!
The crowd is fueling her!
Chat is going crazy!
The whispers!
The crowd!
I think Nani's dead!
Nani's dead!
I think Nani's just dead!
Some brain activity, signs of life.
Ludo's coming down to finish the fight, I guess.
Oh!
Oh, Jesus Christ!
She's not down yet!
She just needed a minute.
Wait, Ludo's on the... begging for mercy right now.
Ludo's a fool to give her the time!
True.
A shot like that to the ego could really shake you up mentally!
Are we going to the stands?
No, we're not.
The Evan caster desk right there?
That's you and me, Snappy.
You see us over there?
Yeah!
But it looks like they're not going to be visiting us today.
Unfortunate.
The steel stairs could be... oh my god!
We do have a fine table for you!
Yeah, for sure.
Oh!
And she's got her by the hair!
Oh my god!
Nan!
Is absolutely killing her!
I'm watching Killer Instinct unfold in real-time!
What's happening?
She's getting abducted back in the arena?
Oh my god!
Nan said, I'm not done yet.
I don't want this match to end.
I still have something to show.
Said you don't want Nan to lose.
Oh, a murder!
And he's going slamming the face down.
He's just staring at her.
Again.
Did they just high five each other?
Okay.
Oh my god!
Oh!
The counter punches!
Nan's taking two, three, and she's out.
Oh my god!
And it's non-stopped!
She looks like she's dropping thunder.
She's just jumping on the back and shaking her.
Oh, almost the wind for Nan, but she's still going!
The armbar?
I don't really know.
That maneuver was very effective.
You can't just hold it on her fingers.
And the screen has gone black.
And Lucho has... What just happened?
Oh no!
The turnaround!
Was that a technical foul?
They reset back to neutral?
Jesus, what just happened?
Lucho just mind wiped the entire crowd and reset the match!
No way!
Devil mind tricks!
True!
The hold person is a really effective ability as it turns out.
I think Nan might be out.
Nan doesn't even know where she is anymore!
Oh no!
What is happening?
The physics should not allow for that!
This is like an epic bowling fly!
And we are back to playing hopscotch with her.
I think Nan is dead.
Oh my god!
Using her body like gravel!
I don't know if Nan gets up from this one.
Nan is not looking good!
I believe I'm seeing a little bit of blood here even.
This is a gruesome one.
Oh my goodness!
Elbow slams!
It's a slaughter!
Lucho is not letting up!
It's not okay!
No!
And the win goes to Lucho!
Holy moly!
The diaper meta is real!
Your winner is...
Lucho!
My god!
Someone get this one on an effing Taylor Swift track!
This guy has got lungs too!
Let me see.
Let's go back to the audience or our casters for the post interview.
I'm effing ready for this junk.
Snuffy!
Did you expect the diaper meta to really make it to the finals twice?
Wait, no.
It's just one match from the finals, right?
You were really almost there.
I'm surprised!
You know, I guess I would say I was hoping for a little bit more of an upset here.
The last couple matches have seemed pretty set in stone.
But I'm excited!
I think nothing is more hype than to see two strong components combine each other into one epic fight battle.
Well, what's here for Lucho and Nan?
What's up guys?
How's that fight looking?
Diaper meta!
Let's go!
Nan, how does it feel to not just get beat up by one of your coworkers but two of them?
Let's just say I came for the match and I came from the match.
Oh!
I feel like I just lost something!
I must say Lucho, your stamina is insane.
But I feel like you'll have...
Are there any opponents that you're looking forward to fighting?
Oh yeah, I'm ready to bring the Irishman down!
Sorry, that's a tall tree to cut down.
I mean, this man has been unstoppable.
Exactly!
We need to get this!
Do you have any plans on taking down Fuyo Man, Lucho?
I think whoever is stinkier gets to take it home, right?
What's the last time you showered?
Oh, that's classified information!
I can't give you that for free!
Oh, shiiiiit!
Well, you heard it here, folks.
Lucho is indeed...
horrendously stinky.
I'm covered in pinchling!
I can't lose this!
Alright, well, I'm still in the fight too, so don't forget that.
It's gonna be me versus two diapers, I feel like.
And maybe someone else, I don't quite remember.
We're gonna have to sell clothes.
We'll need to do our Hard Spins with our final match tickets with how stinky our wrestlers are.
What a mess!
Well, any further words, Snappy, before we send it back over to the main desk?
I think that's everything.
That was an amazing match by you two.
What insane skill.
Thank you both, Lucho and Non, for an amazing fight.
Let's take you back to the main desk.
Thanks, Nogii!
Thank you!
Wooowww!
Okay!
Is that how you thought that was gonna go?
Wait...
Who are you rooting for?
Wow guys, that was an insane fight.
You know, I realized when Fuyume was actually not supposed to do a third fight in a row because I messed up the order.
But like, at this point, Fuyume deserves that bye in the final bracket.
Because we were supposed to send Emma and Fuyume to the final bracket.
But you know, after winning three in the fucking row, Fuyume deserves the bye.
I did not expect Fuyume to travel this far.
So, now that I believe we finished all our brackets, let me bring the brackets up onto the screen for all of you guys.
So you guys see what has happened.
So as you guys know...
Oh, I got some fancy graphics going in for all of you.
Alright, so we have...
Sayu did not win, so let me get rid of Sayu's card.
Alright, Luto proceeds here.
And she does the Teleports Behind You Undertaker special.
So I guess she travels all the way with Fillion in bracket...
I know it says Fillion vs.
Luto.
But if you guys didn't remember, everyone that makes it to the finals here in their bracket...
Actually gets reshuffled.
So...
I cannot be bothered to realign this.
But if you guys didn't know...
Like, Fillion and Luto might not even face each other.
We are going to be spinning a wheel!
We are going to spin a wheel to decide who exactly they are going to be fighting in the end.
So we have Fillion and Luto making it in to the final brackets.
We don't know who they are going to fight though yet.
We are not sure yet.
So that is the results for bracket two.
Bracket one!
Fillionman ends up getting the bye!
Who does send my finals!
Because I made a mistake.
So...
So let me put in the bracket number one for you guys for the visual.
So as you guys know, we have Fillion beating Nana.
And also beating Everland.
So Fillionman automatically gets the bye to the semi-finals.
Because I made a mistake.
And at that point, Fillionman won three times in a row.
And they deserve that win.
If you win three in a row, you might as well get in to the semis automatically.
So whoever wins their next match in the final bracket will be facing Fillionman.
Finally!
Okay, also for those who need a visual.
Bam!
Here she is.
Here is Fillion.
So you guys can see it in the visual alone to see how it goes.
And there she goes.
And then we might as well just put her over Emma because she beat Emma.
So we know only one person is advancing in bracket one.
Finally in bracket three!
We didn't have any matches in bracket three because we actually finished bracket three on day one.
But we'll show you guys who they are.
Who made it into the final.
The final bracket.
Let me pull up bracket three.
Boom!
And then get rid of Fillion real quick.
It is Sarah and Beto.
So Sarah and Beto are going to be heading over to the final bracket.
So how are we going to decide this?
Like we said, we will be spinning a wheel of names of all the people that made it to the final bracket.
And I do have somebody here.
As I mentioned earlier today on the stream.
That's going to be helping me.
Helping me spin the wheel.
It will be like that game.
That Wheel of Fortune game.
No, what is it?
Wheel of Fortune game where she will spin the wheel for me.
And then we'll see who it is.
Are you in the room?
Are you in the room my other person?
Yeah!
I'm here!
Well the item kind of lost.
Well the item...
Wait!
Oh my gosh!
Woo!
Just like a real ghost!
Wow!
Am I good?
Do I need to move?
Look at where I go.
Woo!
She sneaked her way in.
Were you watching some of the games, Ben?
I was.
I was watching some of the games.
Which one was your favorite?
What?
I'm back.
I don't know.
I think Fuyo Man is kind of crazy.
I know.
I do.
If I see Fuyo Man in the alley, I don't think I'm going to make it.
No, I don't.
I think I'm...
I would actually just...
I would kill myself first.
I'll do it for you.
I'll die by my own hands.
Yeah.
I mean it makes sense.
It's Fuyo Man.
Like, I'd agree.
Anyway.
So we got our little wheel here.
I haven't wrote anybody's names yet on the wheel.
So give me a sec as I put... you know, give me a sec.
Tell me some of your favorite moments, Mint, while I write the wheel.
Write the names in the wheel.
Okay, I was half watching and also half eating my spaghetti.
Let's see... what happened?
Oh gosh.
You just talk about Frio Mad if you want to.
I'm completely prepared as a caster, thank you.
I've heard a lot that there's a bunch of diapers going on.
Oh, that's true.
That's true.
Did you plan that, Doki?
Why would you say that?
Like, what about me and diapers?
I don't know.
I just feel like...
I just get this vibe from you.
I don't know what it is.
This diaper vibe?
I don't know.
Yeah, so there's a bunch of diapers going on.
I think, what is it?
Fillion's going against some diaper people.
Well, we don't know yet.
She might not be though from the wheel.
Oh, true.
The wheel.
Yeah, the wheel decides who they're fighting.
Am I missing a person?
I think this could tell it's the wheel of the worst.
The wheel.
Here we go.
It's time to spin that wheel.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
We really only need to spin it twice to be fair because like Frio got the automatic buy.
But, all right.
Here we go.
Spinning that wheel.
So, is this who's going against Frio?
No, it's who's going... No, Frio gets to buy in the semi-finals.
Oh, yeah.
Okay.
So, it's gonna be Luto.
Who is Luto gonna fight?
We're gonna find out.
All right.
Who is Luto?
Luto's either gonna fight Fillion, Vettel, or Sarah.
Oh, Luto and Vettel will be our first match.
Oh.
In the finals bracket, which means Fillion will be fighting Sarah in the next fight.
Okay.
She avoided the diaper.
Let's go.
Yeah.
She avoided...
But whoever... Oh, that's true.
That's true because like whoever wins the battle versus Luto will have to fight Frio man.
So, like... So, there won't be two diapers fighting each other in the finals.
Oh, man.
Yeah.
So...
And then like... And then I guess like... Wait.
Let's pull out the... Let's pull out the brackets here so we can order this up.
Let me pull it out.
Where is my image here?
I'm very prepared as you see, Mint.
Very professional.
Yeah.
I know.
And you always are.
I mean, of course.
Yeah.
So, Sarah will be... Okay.
This will be where Frio got the automatic buy.
And then Sarah and Fillion are...
Yeah.
...down here.
And you see this, right?
Yeah.
I'm watching your stream.
It's a little... It's a little delayed.
It's a little delay.
Okay.
And then there's Luto here.
Luto is going to be fighting Betel down here.
And then Frio gets to automatically advance.
So, Frio will be fighting whoever wins in the Luto versus Betel.
And then Sarah will be fighting Fillion.
Yeah.
Yes.
All right.
Okay.
But we do have a problem, Mint.
We do have a little problem here.
What's that?
Oh, God.
Is that we are sort of missing two fighters at the bottom.
What?
Oh.
Yeah.
I think I did...
I did like a little miscalculation, Mint.
Uh-oh.
Okay.
Wow.
That's so unbranded for you.
Come on, girl.
She can't... She can't count, you guys.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
Okay.
Look.
I mean...
I was...
I'm gonna say, like, you were... you fucking, like, broke into the arena out of nowhere.
And even though I had a security guard... You killed off all our security guards.
Like, what was I supposed to do?
I spent the night hiring a new security guard.
How was I supposed to get in if I didn't kill off the security guards?
Fucking face -throw!
You're a ghost!
I know.
I just... Like, you know, they were... They were looking at me the wrong way.
I don't know what to tell you.
Well, it's a good thing.
I hired a new security guard to tighten up the security.
You wanna meet him?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Alright, yeah.
Sure.
Alright.
Camera, guys.
Bring in... Bring in our new security guard.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Matara?
Wait.
What happened to the security guard I hired?
I'm gonna fight you.
I'm gonna cook you.
I'm gonna eat you.
I'm gonna kick you.
I'm gonna punch you.
I'm gonna throw you off the wall.
I'm gonna pick you up.
I'm gonna twirl you around like a little princess.
Ugh.
Okay.
Mint.
Uh...
Don't kill me!
Oh.
Ugh.
What did she mean by that?
Is she gonna eat me?
Or am I gonna eat you?
What did she mean by that?
I don't know, Mint.
What does she mean by that?
Um...
What did you do?
What didn't I do?
Did you...
Did you bring her over here?
Why is she trying...
Why is she trying to kill all the security guards?
I might have told her that we were like having a coup, you know?
Like that we were...
That I was just like, hey, I'm gonna kill you.
Hey, wouldn't it be cool if we like, you know, did our podcast from...
From the wrestling ring?
In the stadium.
In the ring.
But this one went...
It was already kind of taken, you know?
But we had to...
Well, I guess we have another match to make up the brackets then.
The Podcast Battle of the Century.
Mint versus Matarath.
What's funny is that, like, she's not actually here here at the moment.
No, she like said, hey I'm gonna go on vacation but I'm still gonna kick your ass.
So she said, she said like a spiritual form of her, so to kick Mint's ass.
And she still killed my security guard, so...
She did enough, yeah she did all that she needed to do.
Yeah, like she...
So unfortunately, unfortunately, now there's no more security left in WrestleTuber.
So, but we don't have any crashes after that I'm pretty sure, right Mint?
Just come on in everybody!
No, do not come on in everyone!
Do not come on in!
The door is wide open!
I will start selling off Doki's socks, okay?
Again, what do you mean?
What do you mean again?
I didn't say again!
Oh, I said again!
Oh, did this happen before?
That's what I'm saying!
I was like, when has this happened before?
Alright guys, before we go off to our final bracket...
We are going to have a 10 minute intermission.
The next two matches will be casted by Kai and Octavio.
And I believe that...
There will be a Fillion match.
So Fillion really wanted to cast her own match.
So we'll have her jump right in with Kai and Octavio.
And to cast with them as well.
Anyway guys, we hope you enjoy WrestleTuber so far for day two.
And Mint and I, we will cast the final matches after Octavio and Kai.
So Mint will be casting her own match against Matara.
Her spiritual form of Matara.
Okay, she's not here.
I can whip her ass.
Wait, what would we do if...
Will you be voicing for Matara?
Yeah, I'll voice for Matara.
Okay, alright, we'll see you guys soon in 10 minutes everybody.
Don't go yet!
The finals are going to be here soon.
See you there!
See you in a bit!
2.
The end of the video The battle between the two teams.
The end of the video is coming!
The
ending is coming!
The end of the video is coming!
The ending is coming!
Oh,
shit, sorry!
Let me... let me...
Sorry, sorry.
The intermission was wild.
Oh, wait, it was up on top of me.
Sorry, we needed a couple extra minutes.
Anyway, welcome back!
Welcome back to day two of WrestleTuber.
I hope you guys had a nice break during the intermission.
Be able to stretch your legs, get hydrated, walk around a little bit.
Because it's already been almost three hours of WrestleTuber.
Wow.
Yeah, time really flies by.
Oh, a noticement!
You've got headphones!
Did you buy them from home?
Uh, no, I made these.
I ripped them off some guy's head and I spray painted them in the back.
Yeah, just like how you killed that security guard.
Yeah, I hope you didn't pay like a security deposit or anything.
Because you're not getting that.
Oh, it's alright.
It'll be alright.
It was minimum wage.
It's okay.
Anyway, everybody.
So, we will not be casting yet.
Me and Mitt will not be casting yet.
Instead, when it would be Matara versus Mitt, then we'll rotate in.
So, the first casters going in for the finals will be Octavio and Kai.
Paging Octavio and Kai.
Are you guys ready?
Yes.
Octavio and Kai?
Yeah.
I'm ready.
You guys even remember who is the next matchup?
Oh, Jesus.
Yeah.
You do it this time.
I said it last time.
You say it this time.
It's battle.
It's battle and...
Yeah, yeah.
It's over.
Oh, yeah.
The demon.
The demon Luto.
What's your full name?
Yes.
There you go.
Ara Kaluto.
Are you reading from my OPS right now?
No, totally.
No, no, no.
Tell me that.
All right, guys.
So, Mitt and I will be muting very soon.
So, we're going to take it away to the next casters.
Good luck, guys.
Good luck.
Hey.
We are back.
Oh, my God.
I got a big head again.
Oh, what is this?
Help me.
Hello?
Oh, hello.
Hello.
How are we?
How are you?
You're about to face someone with a very stinky diaper.
Listen, listen.
I have something very brief to say.
I will not stoop to this stick and twisted diaper meta.
Today, I fight as a man, not as a baby.
You just say that because you're scared of the diaper.
Of course I'm scared.
I can't believe a grown man is scared of the diaper.
What are you, a child?
You see what they're doing to people out there?
It's terrifying.
Oh, yeah?
Well, let me sit on you anyway.
Oh, my God.
Listen, I've been watching.
I've seen teleportation.
I've seen green monsters.
I have everything stacked against me.
I'm just a man.
Got any last dying words, my dude?
Yeah.
What?
I'll win.
Nah, no way!
I take this thing all the way.
Diaper meta!
Oh, man.
I don't know how you're going to win without the diaper, but I'm looking forward to see how this match is going to go.
I don't know.
I'm not convinced, man.
Okay, everyone who's had a freaking diaper wins, man.
I'm scared.
True battle.
Battle.
I hope you brought a diaper.
No, no diapers for me.
We're going commando today, baby.
I said, because when you shit yourself...
They're all going to see.
Then I'm braver than the rest.
You know what?
That's fine.
Shit into the air.
That's great.
We shit like men, not cowards.
We don't need diapers.
Can't wait for that chocolate fountain, man.
Can't wait.
I shit in the light.
I don't hide in the shadow.
You expose it to the sun god.
The world will see.
Man, God isn't real.
God isn't real.
I have no words.
I like these two are the craziest, most unhinged people I've known for a bit.
And I'm very scared.
I don't, I don't, I don't, I have no words.
I don't know what else to ask, honestly.
I'm scared.
You know what's crazy?
When even the fucking interviewer is like fucking shaking.
Like, holy shit, man.
What the fuck?
I'm going to win.
That's all you gotta know.
I'm winning.
I'm sitting on you.
I'm watching you.
I have my ass.
This meta ends today.
Nuh uh.
The energy in here is kind of stinky.
Coasters, please take this away.
Please.
Okay.
Alright, we'll save you.
Alright.
I think it's time to get in.
Let's see.
Gotta see this fight happen.
Which ideology, diaper or no diaper, will win today?
In the ring.
This is terrible.
Oh, man.
Oh, my God.
You know what?
It's kind of weird that Bettle kind of looks normal compared to Luto.
Yeah, I was just about to say.
I had to like blink and like process his fucking face for a second.
I was like, wait, hold on.
He's just wearing... Oh, no, no, no.
He... Yeah.
Bettle has that double face thing going on.
He has a painted face and his own face.
Yeah.
Over each other.
Dude, I love how his eyes are like spread out so he could like see everything.
He's a real anime man.
Yeah.
He's looking at things with like every angle, bro.
He sees everything.
Yeah, wait.
We'll see.
We'll see if the non diaper believer will win against a diaper meta believer.
Yeah.
Holding true to the diaper meta.
It's your underworld spawn.
It's Loose!
LUTO!
Yeah!
Woo!
Oh, I love her.
Oh, there we go.
I see it.
I see it now.
Just a vibe.
Damn.
Vibin'.
True, true.
I can't believe we started the frickin' diaper thing.
I know.
We're trendsetters.
Now it's gonna apply to everything.
True, true.
That's just the pure power of the diaper.
It's strong, okay?
Got LUTO vibing the demon from hell!
Ah.
Hell yeah.
You know, this fight is more than just a fight between wrestlers.
Oh yeah?
It's a fight between an ordinary human in Gabus Battle and the demon race.
The demon diaper race.
They're their own breed?
Mm.
Then they shepherd?
True, true.
Dude, do you think that LUTO... Who are you rooting for here?
Wait, do you think that LUTO's like the diaper demon queen then?
You think she's the queen?
You think she's on top?
Yeah!
I also noticed that she keeps her diaper intact with a pin in front.
With a gigantic pin.
True!
Yeah, I remember...
Did you see that?
I saw you bringing that up before.
Yeah, I think if she were smart she'd take that and like stab his eyes out.
But you know, that would be against the rules.
You know.
And opposing the diaper...
It's the jester with the silver hair.
The most charming baby girl himself!
Battle!
Let's go!
That's my senpai!
The weirdest senpai ever!
Oh, come on!
You gotta hype him up more!
He's a jester!
Just call him like, yeah, he's weird!
But I love him and he's great!
He's a man!
The representative of flat supremacy!
Let's fucking go!
Dude, that face is just terrible.
Holy shit.
Also the fastest intro in the business.
Yeah.
He's all business.
Hell yeah.
He didn't come here to play, man.
He came here to win.
Oh yeah, here we go!
Both of them are high flyers actually, now that I realize it.
I wonder who's gonna do the first like fucking jumping attack.
I'm waiting.
Those are my favorites.
Okay.
Oh, dropkick on the face!
But it wasn't enough to like... to drop her?
Oh damn!
Wow!
Oh, shh!
Dude!
The advantage here keeps changing.
Who's winning?
Bettle or Luto?
I can't tell.
Oh my god.
Oh, they keep missing!
They keep jumping and missing!
Ah, there we go!
Dude, Bettle's just freaking agile.
What the fuck?
Oh shit.
One!
Okay, no, no, no.
That'd be too quick.
No, no, no.
Come on, get up buddy, get up!
Bettle here has the makings of a champion.
I'm sure he can recover.
Oh, right in the balls.
Oh no, right in the balls!
Right in the face!
Balls!
Balls in the face!
Bettle's the most important thing!
Balls in parts!
Oh!
Body slams from the top of the rope!
No face, it's over.
Oh my god, you're really down!
Oh, come on!
Oh no, Luto is going crazy.
Luto going feral.
Oh, he dragged my back butt!
No!
Luto does not have any of it!
Was that the balls or the stomach?
Damn, Bettle!
You need to add 300 more pounds to your weight!
Yeah, I don't know, Luto's kinda like flinging him around like way too easily.
Rude.
Oh!
Head to the mat!
Okay.
Oh, reversal by Bettle, that's great.
Oh, yay!
One of Bettle's signature flips!
Hell yeah!
Oh, oh, oh!
Headlock?
What's he doing?
He's setting him up.
Setting him up.
Throwing him around.
Oh no!
Oh, oh, oh!
Crazy!
Yay!
The fake!
To the throw!
Oh shit!
And a pin!
One!
Oh!
Ah!
Don't count Bettle out just because he's 200 pounds less.
That's what makes him so agile, right?
He's made out of skin and bone.
Oh no!
That was insane!
That slam was insane!
And now a submission technique.
Break his leg!
With the legs.
Oh!
Dislocate it!
Oh man.
No, he can't get up.
He can't get up.
Oh!
Right in the nuts again!
What is this targeted attack on the nuts?
Oh my god, wait.
Setting him up again.
Bro, these elaborate setups are so pretty.
Finally it's gonna work in his favor.
Is he gonna do the fake?
Another flip!
Oh, but it didn't work.
Oh!
But he still got her.
Dropkick to the stomach.
Another one!
Oh!
I love that!
And another flip.
Yes.
That's my favorite.
He loves that flamboyant flair.
No!
Come on!
On a one count only?
This is still anybody's game.
Yeah.
Honestly, Beto can be dropped by just a single punch.
Dude, I don't know, man.
I wanna see what happens to Luto if she removes her diaper.
I feel like...
It's like those power limiters, right?
It's like rock leading the fucking weights, alright?
Yeah, that's a power limiter, definitely.
Take out the diaper.
Hell breaks loose on the ring.
She needs that limiter to fight in a normal man's wrestling match.
Oh!
What?
The referee bumped into Luto?
Oh my god!
Oh no.
Get picked out!
One!
Could this be it?
Two!
Oh!
Still not.
Two!
Still not enough.
Flip!
Hey!
Look at those flips!
That's my Oshii!
Two!
Woo!
Almost.
I'm scared.
Dude, Beto's kind of going crazy right now.
Oh, he removed the turnbuckle.
I think Beto might win.
He's running.
Oh!
Okay, okay.
Another flip, maybe.
I'm kind of scared.
I'm scared.
Oh no!
The reversal on Beto!
Oh no, dude!
He took too long to set up.
He took too long!
Oh no, he's going crazy.
Beto's going to go feral now.
Dude!
Oh no!
Right on the cement.
Get back in the ring!
No!
That's not just one!
It's three!
What?!
I'm going to do the three suplex combo!
Oh man.
Come on, Beto!
You were doing so good!
Please, please.
This is so sad.
This is so sad!
Oh, and the Todd!
Oh, you were really going to take that?
Oh no, and the Todd!
Let my boy go!
Let him get up, man!
Let him get up!
No!
Oh man!
Okay, okay.
Come on.
Oh!
He stepped on the chest!
Two inches deep, straight to the heart!
He's going to get up.
He's going to get palpitations after.
Dude!
What happened?!
Oh my god!
Oh!
What happened?!
Yeah, I'm sorry.
He can't breathe after this.
How is he supposed to breathe after this?
His ribs must have punctured his lungs.
True.
He has multiple rib fractures now.
Yeah!
He got the flail chest.
He's going to die.
This is not a wrestling match anymore.
Did the referee move out of the way, man?!
Try to see the action!
Oh my god, this lady's out of the way.
I think Beto paid the referee.
Oh, finish!
That's going to result in concussion.
Flip!
Right in the ass!
Right in the butt!
Ay!
The favorite flip!
And another flip!
It's your favorite flip.
Hell yeah.
I love him.
He looks so slick.
Okay, okay.
Damn!
The backbreaker!
What is this?!
No!
The surprise pin?!
Oh my god!
No!
Not like this!
Okay, we're safe.
Oh no, the diaper to the face!
Oh my god, I thought she was going to sit on his face!
You can hear the squelch from here!
Oh, dude!
The stink!
It's filling up the arena!
Jesus!
Woo!
Beto still has a chance.
A kick to the back.
Oh, do I just kick the diaper off?!
He's going to remove the turnbuckle again!
Oh my god!
What?!
He's removed two now!
What is he going to do about it?
Fucking flip, man!
Oh my god!
He can't just...
He can't just body slam normally.
He has to flip.
Yeah, got to add a little flip.
Oh my god!
Crazy!
Uses his body as a weapon!
A fireball!
Dude, he's a fucking weapon!
He needs a permanent one for him!
Humanity will not give in to the devil and Satan!
Okay.
Oh, the taunt!
Oh, the battle didn't like that!
Oh, headbutt right to the ribs!
Disrespect!
This is what you get for thumping!
It was a cool spear, though.
It was, it was.
Oh, this might be it!
This might be it!
One!
Two!
Oh, come on!
It's still anybody's game.
Oh, another...
Oh, what's he doing?
Oh, top of the rope!
Oh, I thought he was going to take it off again.
Oh, come on, do the jump.
Come on!
Finger guns, finger guns!
Come on, do the flip!
You know you want to!
Max left!
Oh!
Fucking broke his ass!
He missed!
Failed!
That little, little butt...
Oh, why?
Little squish...
Oh, what is that?
He said, yeah, you're going to fucking kick me in the balls!
That's illegal!
Yeah, I think I can kick you in the balls!
Think again!
The illegal move!
Two!
Three!
I can't believe it!
Holy shit!
He fucking won!
I can't believe it!
With a low blow to win the match!
Your baby girl is all grown up!
No diapers for the winner!
Bravo!
I can't believe it!
I can't believe what I'm seeing!
Holy shit!
That was so...
That was beautiful!
Oh my God, I have like a tear in my eye.
Oh, man.
Oh, my God.
That was great!
Ladies and gentlemen, Bettle's the motherfucking winner!
Oh, we should be the diapers for the key!
What a Chad move!
Holy shit!
The dirtiest move he did!
I didn't know Luto could lose like that!
Dude, I didn't think it could get dirtier than the diaper, but here we are.
I...
Yeah.
My fucking balls!
He kicked me in the balls!
You can't...
You can't talk to a man on his fucking balls like that!
I thought you were fighting like a man, not like a fucking chicken!
Well, if I remember correctly, you did it too!
I can't go for the balls!
I was just matching my opponent!
What can I say?
I...
Bettle, I need to know the thought process of grabbing Luto's balls.
Why...
Why did you do it?
Listen, to defeat your opponent, you attack the source.
The diaper is the source.
You will go for the heart!
I...
The diaper heart!
Throw it!
Was it warm?
Oh, it was warm.
But it was not as warm as my burning passion.
Was it big?
Was it big enough for you, Elise?
Ah, yeah.
It's
a match, but I will not lose in size!
Oh!
Wow.
The gay demon versus the goth lesbian.
Who would have thought that the goth lesbian would win?
Well, you know what?
Luto, you're pretty calm.
I'm just...
I'm pretty confident, but I don't know.
It ended up not paying off.
Kind of sad to say.
I thought the diapers were the key, but it wasn't.
More like, uh...
More like LUSTO.
Oh, wow.
That was my senpai!
He's so funny!
Oh, you're so funny.
I'm gonna...
I'm just gonna call you cock grabber from now on.
Ball grabber!
You're a ball grabber!
I will wear that title with pride.
Ball grabber!
I'm gonna...
The Ball Grabber Battle was made today.
The title was so, like, wrong and so...
I'm...
My brain can't process this.
The myth, the legend.
My brain can't process this right now.
It's too late for me.
The Great Grabber of Balls!
It's no honor!
Battle wins!
The more you say it, the more I question my life choices.
His name has B and L, which is present in balls.
Wow.
So true.
So that makes sense.
Yeah, so true.
So true.
I need to get a raise.
Cool.
I need a raise.
Jesus Christ!
Well, congratulations, battle, I guess.
Thank you.
Congratulations!
Hey, that was a great fight!
Thank you so much!
Congrats!
Even though it was really dumb!
For that amazing, amazing performance.
Those clips are insane.
Never forget about it.
I will never forget.
Good.
You just started looking.
I'm going to go to Ludo's Villain Arc right now.
One day, everyone will know the wrath of the diaper queen!
One day they will!
Fuyo
diaper man is truly supposed to be!
Battle's going to go up against the Fuyo man!
Are you ready?
Are you scared?
Wait, what?
Yeah.
I am?
Yes, you are.
You are going to be up against Fuyo man.
Why did I win?
Oh my god.
Maxlok battle versus the leprechaun?
Gotta get out of here!
That's a match for the centuries.
Wow.
Yeah, I am so...
I am ready for Fuyo man to beat him up.
Next?
Alright, now we are going on to the next!
We are the next contestants.
Yeah!
Do you guys know them?
Maybe.
Yeah.
Do you know who is fighting?
Maybe.
Yeah, Kai.
Will you be able to tell?
Kai knows.
What?
No, you know.
Kai knows.
What?
What did you say?
What do you mean by...
You know them.
You said their names before.
It's...
Let's say it together.
Oh my god.
It's...
Fillion...
Fillion!
Yeah!
And...
Sarah!
Yes!
Yeah!
How do you feel about the casters not knowing who you guys are?
Wait, what happened?
Wait, I am not animated anymore?
Did I get fired?
How?
Yeah, you got fired.
I bought Tenta!
We had a bunch of cups already.
Can't afford it anymore.
All right.
I'm sorry.
I'm Indy now.
What can I say?
It's definitely what it is.
All right.
Like, who am I up against?
Sarah?
Oh, it's the snake lady.
Oh, look, look, Fillion.
You probably don't know who I am, but I don't really care because I have a philosophy.
No, I know who you are.
It's pretty simple.
What?
I'm going to be so good that they can't ignore me.
So that goes for you, my opponent.
It goes for the audience and it goes for everyone.
Because look, people might not know me out there.
They might not know me.
They might not even like me, but I don't need to be liked.
I need to win.
So I'm going to play the villain if it means I get that card.
We're taking a villain arc.
Yeah.
I respect it.
Damn.
Look, I remember you.
The pilot is very spicy today.
You're the one that killed Doki Bird, aren't you?
I am.
Oh, Bogan.
I casted you yesterday.
I saw all of your moves.
I observed them.
Anything you do, I can dodge.
You understand me?
I will avenge Doki.
You've learned from me.
You've learned from Doki and you think you can take me on now, huh?
Yeah, I don't need to take you on.
I'll just kick you in the nuts.
Learned that one in battle.
So, yeah, you're pretty much downloaded and you only took up one gigabyte on my hard drive.
I'm sorry.
Kick the snake in the nuts.
Oh, uh, yeah.
I think you'll find that anatomically incorrect.
I mean, I don't know.
You could kick Sarah in the nuts, but she's got a whole fucking snake, right?
You can kick her in the nuts.
She'll just yank you.
You can yeet that snake.
How do you counter that?
Grabbing the snake by the balls, too.
Yeah, true.
The more you know.
Listen, I will avenge Doki.
I will flip on your face and I will beat you into a pulp.
I will take your teeth and remove the venom from them.
And then I'll sell your skin as a purse.
You understand me?
You tried, but you failed.
I'm not necessarily a venomous snake.
I'm one of the types that can constrict you.
I'll have you tapping before long.
Let's just say that.
I don't care what your kinks are.
What's up with get down those fights?
I think they're ready.
Well, at least there's no kink shenanigans.
They're ready.
Get them out there.
We accept all kinks here.
A very accepting environment.
We love that.
All right.
We got to throw them in the ring.
Get them in the ring.
Get out!
All right.
We got to throw them in the ring.
Who do you think is going to win, man?
I don't know.
It's a difficult one.
Fillion is a high flyer.
Both Bogan has a snake.
She can't fucking...
She's got a fucking snake, man.
Like, I don't know.
I don't know.
Let's see if she can pull off what she learned from the battle match.
Fillion better be thankful that she won't bring out the snake during the battle.
Usually she brings out the snake at the end.
That's true.
We'll see.
But who knows?
Maybe she'll change her mind.
Slithering her way to the stage.
Oh, what did she do?
The serpent that doesn't take shit from anybody.
The serpent storyteller herself.
Sarah.
I got to harmonize there.
Where is she?
Sarah.
She forgot the snake backstage, all right?
She left it in the break room.
You're cute.
Where is she?
Where is Sarah?
Where is this damn powerlifter?
Don't tell me she got cold feet.
Sarah.
There she is.
Let's fucking go, Sarah.
Finally.
Look at those tight shorts.
They're very tight.
Hell yeah.
Dude, she's got so much muscle.
Holy fuck.
Fucking Bill.
Holy crap.
I'm not quite sure.
Is that hair or like a...
I don't know.
No, that's hair.
Yeah, that's hair.
It's actual hair.
I thought it was like a thing, like a cloth.
Oh, okay.
No, no, no.
It's her hair.
She takes such good care, you know?
It's like so flowy.
Oh my God.
Crawling on the floor.
That's intimidating.
Immersing herself in what it means to be a snake.
Dude, I don't know.
I feel like half of these intros are so intimidating.
I'd just be scared shitless.
I don't know how Fillion's going to deal with all the diapers, man.
She's just going to have to like shit on...
I'm sorry.
I can't get over the diapers, man.
I can't.
It's the end of an era.
I need to get over it, but it's stuck, man.
I can't.
I can't accept reality.
I mean, diaper meta, our legacy.
That's our legacy as casters for today.
You bet next year's WrestleTuber will have a bunch more diapers.
Yeah, I know.
Next year's WrestleTuber, everybody's obligated.
Everyone.
Diaper.
Wrestle diaper.
Everybody has a custom diaper.
And you can buy diaper merch in the future.
Right?
Oh my God.
No, not the merch.
Dude, actually though.
No, no, no.
Actually, no.
No, I'm just kidding.
No.
Actually, yes.
If I had a diaper, I'd want it to be...
That's useful.
Diapers are useful.
It's true.
And it's also the great equalizer.
All of us wore a diaper before.
That's true.
Yeah, true.
I'm sure dragons wear diapers.
Well.
Well, I mean, maybe when I was like a wee dragon, but not anymore because I'm a big girl, obviously, and I'm very old and wise because, you know, I'm like a god and I'm like old like that.
Well, when we're super old, like geriatric age, we will wear diapers again.
No, no, no.
Dragons were just like built different.
Sorry to say.
So we just don't.
We're just better.
Oh, okay.
Yeah.
Okay.
I see.
Yeah.
But maybe you could be the first.
Who knows?
Start a movement.
Set the trend.
Yeah, trendsetter.
This intro still goes on and on.
Dude, it's so fucking long.
It's been an hour.
Both bugging.
All right, there we go.
Get out of here.
Stop.
Thank you.
Get out of here.
Here we go, guys.
Oh, my God.
All right.
Here comes Fillion.
And making an appearance outside of VR chat.
Oh, my God.
Here to grace our presence, it's Fillion.
Yeah, yeah, yo.
Look at those moves.
Yeah.
I don't know what those moves are called.
A little dancey dance.
Yeah, no, me neither.
I don't know any moves anyone's making today.
Are those the moves?
I don't know wrestling moves.
I don't know dance moves.
TikTokers use these days.
Oh, do you know, Octavia, do you know how to hit the gritty?
Yeah.
You do?
It's like, I do this.
Yeah.
So I'm like, oh, my God.
See that?
Get it.
Yeah, that was really impressive.
Yeah.
That was so impressive.
So, I think I need more practice, honestly.
Me too.
Fillion should have done the gritty.
Zero out of ten intro.
Yeah, what the heck is this dance?
This dance is actually very, like, very old.
Yeah, this is what the kids do nowadays, all right?
We're doing the...
This is like 2008 dance.
When were we hitting the gritties?
All right, this is...
You're old.
Get out of here with that shit.
This was the year where we all had eyeliner on.
It's that old.
I just want to hear about hitting the gritty in skibbity toilet.
That's it.
Okay, here we go.
I don't know what to bet my money on.
Fillion versus Bulk Bogan.
I don't know, too.
Though I kind of want to...
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh, whoa.
All right, that's just like fucking whiplash.
Holy shit.
Those signature Fillion flips.
I can't wait to see what goes on here.
What's Bulk Bogan's strategy?
I think...
I think Bulk Bogan is a high flyer.
There we go.
Bulk Bogan is pure.
Yeah, no, I don't think so.
He's got the strength.
Pure muscle.
Yeah, I was going to say he's pure muscle.
Exactly.
Whoa!
Just rode on Fillion, the poor little cat.
Is that a cat?
He casually breaks your spine.
Ouch.
Oh, oh, the flip.
Oh.
Oh!
Damn!
Whoa!
The people's elbow.
Damn.
But Bulk Bogan's very aggressive.
Ah!
Sticking the landing every time.
Oh, another elbow.
That's inaccurate.
Fillion seems to be a little more aggressive.
She seems to be moving at times two speed.
Yeah, I was just about to say that.
She's like so fucking speedy right now.
Oh my God.
She got that Final Fantasy haste spell on.
I thought that was me.
Or drugs.
I don't know.
She's bringing out her A game, right?
Oh, pinned already.
Oh, a pin already.
One, two, two.
Oh, okay.
I thought that was not good for her.
That was like, holy shit.
Too early.
That's too early.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh.
What are you...
What's going on here?
Are you setting up?
Oh.
Yeah, she's like, get out of here.
Flip.
Oh, man.
That was so cool if you landed it.
A dropkick to the back.
That's gotta hurt.
A herniated spine.
Ravager or something.
Come on, do it, do it, do it, do it, do it.
Oh, butt to the face.
Oh, so lucky.
A non-diaper butt to the face.
Yeah.
So lucky.
I should not wear a diaper.
Just straight up like bone structure and fat.
Oh, flip.
Oh.
That was sick.
Props to the cameraman.
The cameraman is doing great.
Dude, right?
I'm like this fucking referee that drives me through the roof every time.
True.
Whoa.
Oh, my God.
Fucking Satan downed another one.
From the ring.
My God.
How does she not get dizzy from doing all those flips?
Oh.
What was that?
Okay.
Oh.
Ah.
Right on the cement.
Oh.
Come on.
Get her.
Get her down.
Right in front of the crowd.
Look at all those three men in the black shirts.
Yeah.
The crowd is so excited.
Okay.
So hyped.
Keep them inside the ring.
Yeah.
So you can pin them when you need them to.
Get in the ring.
Oh.
They're staring each other down.
One in heaven, one in hell.
Oh.
Holy shit.
Do it.
Just carried like a twig.
Oh.
Head to the turnbuckle.
That's got to hurt as well.
That's even worse though.
Yup.
Ah.
Whoa.
I thought it was whatever.
What?
Huh?
You didn't tell me Bulk Bogan was also athletic and flexible like that.
Oh my god.
The setup.
I didn't know she did that as well.
Oh.
Here we go.
One.
This referee is so freaking slow.
Two.
I know.
Right.
Nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah.
Fillion is too slippery.
Too slippery and thin.
Yeah.
She's too fast.
Oh.
Butt to the face.
Again.
Oh.
Pull her arm off.
Yeah.
Grab her by the hair.
I just realized Fillion is in like a generic dance practice outfit.
Yeah.
She...
Listen.
She's not here for the bells and whistles.
She's getting to...
Yeah.
No.
She had a warm up.
All right.
She was warming up.
Yeah.
Oh man.
Fillion actually rivals Gavis Battle in all the...
Oh.
I need to see a...
Maybe even better.
I need to see a Fillion versus Battle fight just for all the flips, dude.
Oh yeah.
Oh, shit.
Oh.
Kick in the air.
Gnarly.
Converse to the face.
Oh.
Head down.
One.
Two.
Three.
Oh.
Not yet.
Damn.
Now, this seems to be...
This feels like it's going to be a long battle.
Yeah.
We'll see.
Why did Ludo just like dramatically like roll up?
Like, oh God.
Not again.
Oh.
She set herself up for that one, honestly.
Her own butt to Bulk Bogan's face.
Bony and thin.
Oh.
That's got to hurt.
Oh, the ankles.
Oh my God.
Oh no.
This is just...
Bulk Bogan is...
I know.
I was about to say, I can't watch.
This is just...
Ludo, come on.
Yeah.
Get it together.
What?
Bulk Bogan, you're snake.
Oh.
Think of your...
Oh my God.
An elbow from the top of the rope to the cement.
What?
Oh my God.
Fillion just won't let her get up.
Fillion, don't kill Bulk Bogan.
Her snake won't know what happened to her owner.
Oh God.
Oh, what?
The snake is waiting at home for Bulk Bogan and she never comes back.
That's so sad.
Oh my God.
Snake, where are we at?
Listen, we're putting up the snake up for like auction.
Everybody put your...
Oh, I'm sorry.
Put your auctions in the chat.
How much are you...
How much you want to buy the snake for?
We need to find a new owner for Bulk Bogan's snake.
Damn.
Dude, I feel like they should already be counting like Ludo.
It's just like not getting up.
Yeah.
Oh no, there she goes.
There she goes.
She's not done yet.
She's not out to fight yet.
Come on, strike back.
Don't let her treat you like that, Ludo.
Oh, yeah.
It's the reversal.
Let's go.
Oh, right in the gut.
Reversal.
Reversal, Sarah.
Oh, how do you block an arm that thick?
Dude, you can't.
She's just a fucking tank.
Whoops.
Oh.
Yo.
Oh, what am I watching?
The wrestling or Olympics?
Dude.
These flips are fucking insane.
Feelings in the wrong place.
She should be at the fucking gymnastics Olympics, all right?
Not the fucking WWE.
But it's not on me to judge her career path.
One, two, three.
Oh, she's not out.
This is it.
That was it.
Killian won.
I'm fucking huge.
Against Bucky Bogon.
Holy crap.
Bucky Bogon.
No, not Sonic the Hedgehog, but it's Killian.
Yes.
Fucking congrats.
That was insane.
Dude, I thought she was going to whip out that snake, but she didn't.
Ah, she should've done it.
Fuck Bogon.
All of that gym.
All of that workout for what?
Fillion, Fillion, why are you flexing?
You have nothing there bro.
You look like a toothpick.
Why are you flexing?
It's alright, listen, I can't talk shit.
She fucking won.
So it doesn't fucking matter.
Yeah true.
Muscles actually don't matter if you think about it.
What?
Alright, let's go see what they have to say.
That's just Fillion bone and tendons.
How the fuck did you...
like...
How did you raise him up?
How could you flip him?
I need to know!
I used the power...
of God in anime...
and I showed her my snake.
And it was over before it began.
Like I said, new purse.
Is it a Pato?
Is it a Gucci?
No, it's a Sarah.
Alright.
I just have one thing I want to say.
My name's not...
Sarah.
It's not!
It's Luto.
It is...
Sarah Nagare.
Remember that name!
I'm coming back.
And I'm coming back with a vengeance.
You better believe it.
This is not the last time you've seen me.
So remember it next time.
Hey, hey.
Let me know when you can touch your toes.
Alright?
What?
Snakes don't have toes.
Alright.
Well, let me know when you put them on and then touch them.
Oh, whoa.
I put them on.
I feel like...
Let me just get my fake toes and I'll...
I do find some feet.
I just find some feet and strap them on real quick.
It's like Velcro, you know?
I'll just... I'll just... I'll throw them on.
It's okay.
I didn't know Fillion liked feet.
A snake with toes?
Hey, hey.
No kinkshaming.
I'm not here for the feet.
I'm here for the snake.
Give me gin.
I'm keeping that, nerd.
I want his little mustache.
Oh, God.
True, he does look very distinguished.
He does have a mustache.
Yeah, I just realized that.
He's very distinguished.
He's very gentle.
Saurabh, because you did fuse with Jyn, does he have anything to say?
Yeah, I do have something to say, and that is...
Are we allowed to swear on this, or is this family friendly?
I've sworn a bunch of times, so...
I mean, I don't know.
At least if you get in trouble, we get in trouble together, so...
Do it.
No, I'll be good to everyone.
You fackers!
Frick!
I'll be back, and I'll be snakier than ever.
You just watch now.
I'm gonna get these snaky dogs out, and you're gonna be facking licking them next time.
Oh, my God!
You know what?
I'm looking forward to your comeback, alright?
I will remember this.
I'm so immersed.
Alright.
Well, I believe now we will actually be rotating the camera.
So, thank you guys for your...
Thank you.
It was fun.
What a great fight.
It was.
Yeah.
Congrats.
I'll carry on your legacy.
You and Dokis.
Thank you.
Take it all the way, Fillion.
I'm ready to go my way.
I don't like this!
You're supposed to be mean!
I'm still in my Villanox.
No, I'm sorry.
I'm not in your friendship.
Yo, sorry.
I gave you my PayPal.
What's going on?
I'll come out later.
Don't worry.
Alright.
Okay.
So we're rotating casters.
Behind the scenes Doki.
I'm gonna kick you guys off the facking casting table now.
Goodbye.
Snap them and they're gone.
And then, we're gonna roll up now.
It's our show now.
Yes!
A huge thank you to Kai and Octavio for casting.
That was their last match to cast.
And now, it's just Mint and I left for the final couple of matches.
And are you excited, Mint?
You're gonna be fighting the spirit form of Matara.
Oh, everybody needs to be ready.
I'm ready to fight.
I'm ready to pull out.
I'm not afraid to bite.
I just have to say that.
It's sad that Matara just can't really...
Oh yeah.
I'll speak for Matara.
Okay, hold on.
Okay, I got it.
Okay, here's a...
We're starting the rough talk, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Go at it.
Hag fight.
Okay.
Matara-kun!
You are a bug.
What do you have to say about that?
I am a bug.
And I have a lot to say about that.
I have...
For you, man?
Is that you?
No, this is Matara-kun.
This guy is always so needed.
Matara-kun!
I didn't realize you were related to Fuyumen.
Matara?
I think, um...
I might be a great great great descendant.
That's why I'm also so ugly.
Oh, stop!
Oh!
What do you have to say to Mint Matara?
I have to tell her that I hope she uh, kind of...
I hope she eats my flesh and I...
That's what I hope.
What?
That's...
No, the only foot you'll be eating is my foot, Matara-kun.
Interviewer, are you not gonna ask more questions, interviewer?
I...
I feel like I'm out of place, Tama, to be honest.
I feel like I'm very out of place.
I shouldn't be here.
Goodbye.
Goodbye, all of us.
You just want to do your job!
Ask her some really tough questions!
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
Ask Matara some questions!
Any questions!
Any questions?
I... I need...
I need to know, since you're not physically here, are you...
Are you technically like a ghost spirit as well?
So it's like ghost on ghost fighting?
Ghost on ghost action?
That's a really great question.
Um...
Why are you laughing?
Why are you laughing, Matara?
I think Matara is choking.
We gotta call an ambulance.
We need to know the harmless maneuvers.
She's choking.
We need a resurrector.
We need to get the electric postage.
She needs to come back to life.
Um, what was the question?
I forgot the...
Yeah?
What was the question?
Okay, but Tyra, how are you going to beat Min?
Yeah?
Uh, I'm gonna probably first, uh, I'm gonna show her my boobs and I'm gonna show her my butt.
And then she'll be too embarrassed to fight me anymore.
Oh, damn, Min.
My personality is shit, so it's all I've got.
Oh, I...
Well, Min, wait.
Well, I need to know now, Min, do you like ass and boob?
I'm an ass and a boob.
Ass is life and boob is hometown.
Are you gonna go ham on her boobs?
I'm gonna motorboat the fuck out of those boobs.
I'm gonna get in there, I'm gonna get in there nice and juicy, I'm gonna...
I'm gonna get in there.
I'm gonna get in there real good.
What the fuck?
Well, I guess we gotta take to the ring then so she can make her dreams come true, guys.
I'll see you there, Min.
Gotta make that dream come true.
Whoa, I forgot to kick them off of the stage too.
Give me a sec.
Whoops.
Sorry about that.
There we go.
He's taking a nap.
We had to drag him out of the room.
He had a rough time.
Well, Min, how do you feel about fighting Matara?
Oh my god.
This is my first time seeing the bottom.
We contacted someone to secretly make a wrestler for Min and Matara.
Told Min, I was like, you're gonna enjoy this.
Oh my god, it's so good.
I saw the intro.
You're definitely gonna enjoy the intro.
Oh no.
Okay.
She's hungry.
Her big meaty claws are ready.
Flying in her cockroach stunt double.
It's Matara-Khan!
Oh my god.
What is she...
She has her wine!
She's Fortnite emoting.
She brought her red solo cup.
Oh my god.
She really did.
See, she's not here to fight.
She's here to party.
Yeah, she's here to party.
It's mom time.
She's got her wine ready and she's ready to party.
Look, she's showing off her butt to everybody.
Her boobs to everybody.
Yeah.
You're not exclusive.
Oh, she did not see that camera.
Those glasses are not helping you, Matara.
What are those gringers?
Oh my god.
Woah!
For free?
Oh my god.
She's showing everything.
Look at that dance.
Is that what she's gonna do to me?
Cause me-ow.
Woah.
Which part?
The feet or the...?
Damn calm down, man.
There's plenty of Matara to go around.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
I mean, I actually don't even know what the size differences are in the ring.
It'll be interesting to see.
All right, there you're coming up!
Evil beware.
You're in for a scare.
Projecting herself onto the ring is our own ghost maid, dressing up as Solid Snake...
Oh my gosh, she took off her jacket.
Oh, there you are.
I like the little...
Oh!
Oh my gosh!
Why are you looking at Min?
I'm observing the situation going on here.
Oh, you're calculating right now.
Making those math equations in your head.
I'm seeking out every exit of this building after it explodes.
I'm gonna blow it up.
Oh, you're observing alright.
Oh, I don't actually wish this...
What are you...
That's $100,000 of explosion right there.
Yeah, and I've got an ass to beat, so...
Turn around.
Oh, wait!
That leaves nothing to imagination.
Not at all.
Like, who am I?
Call my name!
Say my name!
Min!
Lowly!
I can't hear you!
Oh my god, I'm going huge with power.
Give your... This is your spirit bomb.
Alright, let's see.
Oh, she's got... Make sure she's doing her stretches right now.
Oh, I'm so laid back.
I'm ready for this.
I'm so ready.
Oh my god, look how bulky...
Oh my god, she's...
It's fine!
I'm getting her defenses low!
I mean, you got the feet right up to your face.
She ain't wearing any shoes.
It's okay!
You know, the bigger they are, the harder they fall, right?
What is she doing?
She's voting on me!
This is so rude!
She's doing her bomb dance on you!
Oh my god!
This is a Fortnite avatar!
I know I look like Snake, but come on!
Oh no, I don't feel very confident anymore after that.
Oh, oh.
Oh god.
It's fine.
I'm gonna...
It's the Lord Farquaad cut, okay?
They did me dirty.
I mean, you're so hopeless!
She brought you back to the ring!
I win it on my own!
Thank you very much!
Oh, she missed!
Those glasses are the wrong prescription, Matara!
Everyone has the same sign in the background.
There's like 15 people.
Come on, get up, Matara.
Look, she's lazy.
She's lazy.
She's like, no, you come to me, Mint.
You come to me.
No, she's laying on the ground.
She hurt her hip.
Bro, this is so...
This is a hack fight.
We gotta be careful.
Woah!
This choke on Matara?
Oh my god!
It's my thighs!
My thighs!
The choke hold of the century!
Oh, and then Matara's gonna bring Mint up.
Ooh!
Already?
No!
One!
Okay, Mint is in for it.
Couldn't even get to two.
Yeah, didn't even get to two.
That was a bit too early, Matara.
Yeah.
She's ready to play with me some more.
I'm just rolling over.
Oh my god, the jump, the recovery!
Oh, I think so.
The ref?
Come on, get out of the way, Mat.
Holy shit!
She's flipping, she's flying.
She's like, she's using her wings.
She's cheating!
You're literally a ghost.
Yeah, but I don't look very ghostly here.
She still looks like a damn bug.
What is this?
You can literally float.
Oh my god!
Bro!
I thought she was gonna pin me like that.
Yeah, she did a fucking split on you.
She loves showing off.
Come on, get up, Mint.
What are you doing?
I mean, she has all the time she needs in the world.
Oh!
She cannot split on Mint.
I'm just like Solid Snake.
There's no microwave that can defeat me, everybody.
Alright, and Mint is grabbing onto Matara.
She's doing the flip.
Oh, but Matara, she's punching back on her head!
That's a concussion right there.
Yeah, why did you grab her like that, Mint?
What did you do?
Oh, the second pin!
Another pin!
One!
Oh, another one.
Matara's doing these pins a little bit too early.
I got the endurance.
Oh my god, I'm actually crawling like a rhythm mic.
That's just sad, Mint.
That's just...
No, that was me showing how sneaky I am in the middle gear.
True, true.
Mint is performing the sneaky crawl right there.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I don't think Matara saw her.
She's like, where did she go?
Oh, oh, and Matara got out of the pin, but doesn't matter!
Oh my god!
Holy shit!
The London Bridge suplex!
Of course I can pull off the London Bridge.
I coined the term!
Of course!
The London Bridge was created by Mint in the 1980s.
Yeah.
When she was just 70 years old.
A wee 70.
Yeah.
Oh my god, she just hopped over me!
Oh, and she hopped over you, but it didn't matter!
It didn't even matter.
She's just gonna keep gut-punching you and then another fucking grab?
I can take a punch.
I can take a, you know?
Okay, to be fair, you took like a thousand.
Okay, move.
Oh, and she couldn't even get up from that jump!
Doesn't look too good for you, Mint.
Doesn't look... oh!
She grabbed her feet?
Grabbed the grippers.
They're huge.
They're easy to grab, you know?
But Matara's coming back up.
She's not gonna go down without a fight.
Oh, I'm gonna ride her like a damn pony!
Come on!
Nay for me!
Nay!
This is some horseplay shit that we're seeing live!
Mint, bring in the bedroom to that ring!
I don't know what's going on.
What are you doing?
That's my tokusatsu.
And another!
It's a blur pin!
Here we go!
One!
Two!
Three!
Yes!
I got everybody!
Mint!
That's... I was actually very surprised, because like Matara came in fucking flailing right away.
She had no endurance, man.
Yeah.
The winner is...
Solid
Mint taking in another win.
Look at her go.
I guess we gotta interview the loser then, Matara.
Oh no!
How does Matara have to say?
Uh...
Matara, you talked very lowly about yourself, and I think that may have affected your performance.
I don't think so, so much.
I think, uh...
You know, I think, uh... I don't think.
I have a concussion.
Do you recall how many glasses of wine you had before you stepped into the match?
That's a great question.
Thank you for asking.
Um, you know, uh...
But, uh...
I have to say is...
Oh no!
Matara's having a stroke!
She's gonna live in here in cockroach life right now!
Someone call the ambulance!
She's having a stroke!
Somebody take her away from the town medical home!
Guys, okay...
Yeah, she's gone.
Alright, so, sorry...
Call an ambulance.
Please, for me.
Alright, so, um... Unfortunately...
Um...
She used up too much of her endurance and stamina in that match and it over-exerted her poor little heart.
She's a real hag, you guys.
Like, actually.
And what are you?
Yeah!
Anyway...
Anyway, so...
Unfortunately, um... Let's send some thoughts and prayers to Matara and hope she recovers...
Uh...
From that heart attack after that match, guys.
Thoughts and prayers to Matara.
Thoughts and prayers.
Guys, thoughts and prayers.
Um...
And we'll... The WrestleTuber will make sure to send her a bouquet of flowers at her hospital bed.
Because she will pull through, guys.
We will know she can pull through.
Anyway!
It's up to the next match-up!
The semi-finals!
With Fuyauman and Benta!
Do we have Fuyauman and Benta?
For the interview room?
Oh, God.
I... I'm... I'm... I'm scared.
Why?
Why are you scared?
Tell us, Benta.
I've seen that thing in the ring.
It's not human.
Thing?
Excuse me.
Fuyauman is Fuyauman.
It's a monster!
He has a name!
Fuyauman!
The pronouns are Fuyo.
Fuyauman is Fuyauman.
It's Fuyauman.
Fuyauman, the strong little man.
Oh, God.
Let's just chill.
It's fine.
Listen, I made a promise.
You made a promise?
You made a promise to who?
I made a promise.
I beat the diaper meta.
The diaper meta is going down.
He's so smart.
Or I die in the ring.
Does this mean you're also going to grab Fuyauman by the balls?
If I have to.
I think there's going to be a diaper in the way of the balls, though.
Yeah.
How would you... There's so much padding.
How would you get through it?
With enough force, anything is possible.
Whoa.
I like that confidence.
You got a grister.
Got you.
Fuyauman.
Fuyauman, how will you prevent him from grabbing your balls?
Fuyauman destroy.
What?
What do I do?
You know, it's simple.
I like it.
Yeah, he's so simple.
He's such a man of his words, you know?
All those ladies out there swooning right now for Fuyauman.
Beto, come on, Beto.
Say something for the fans, Beto.
Just give us some confidence.
Fan service.
Come on.
What is our fan service?
To the fans.
The fans.
I'm going to win.
I'm going to take this thing all the way.
I got defeat of Fuyauman.
I got to win.
I got to win this whole thing.
I got to win it.
That's right, Charlie.
You're going to win the whole thing.
The whole thing.
We believe in you, Charlie.
You got this.
Oh, come on.
Good luck, Petty.
We'll see you in the ring.
All right.
It seems like... I mean, people are voting for Beto.
People think Beto might win.
I tend to find the nervous ones, they have a wild side to them.
That's so true.
People underestimate just how strong they really are.
Maybe Beto is just giving that low confidence acting.
So Fuyauman will not expect it when Beto grabs the balls.
Well, it's also just like when you push him into a corner, their survival instincts come out.
Oh, true.
Fight or flight.
They go fucking wild.
Yeah.
I saw what you did to Matara.
I know.
I saw you fucking go wild.
I always do.
Oh my God.
Oh, there you are.
The first round of the semi-finals.
You know him.
The last diaper standing.
It's Fuyauman!
It's going to be pretty exciting.
If Fuyauman wins this match, she would have won four matches in a row.
That's insane.
That is.
Yeah.
She got that back-to-back three wins.
Nobody expected it, too.
Are you sure?
I mean...
Okay.
Well, the third one...
It's the luck of the Irish, everybody.
Oh, the luck of the Irish.
You're right.
Well, maybe not luck.
Maybe it's all pure skill.
I mean, looking like that.
Wowee.
Yeah.
Oh, spreading those legs for everybody to see.
Very confident.
Fuyauman hides nothing.
Yeah.
He doesn't need to hide.
He knows what he's got.
I mean, look, his shirt is off just now.
Oh, he has a medal!
The diaper denier...
Beto!
You know, I heard Beto has, like, massive...
Max luck going in.
He might have, like...
You know how, like, in the skill set, you, like, go, like, skill attributes, you go max on, like, HP, strength, and everything?
I heard, like, Beto, he is, like, negative on everything, like, intellect, defense, strength, but the luck...
That's where he puts all the skill points in.
Oh.
Sometimes that's all you need.
I know.
I mean, like...
It took him this far.
He's literally in the semi-finalists now.
Yeah.
I mean, those eyes have seen everything.
And I mean...
They are viewing everything.
Like a goddamn chameleon.
Oh, Beto, why are you running away?
This is the semi-finals, Beto!
Elbow him!
Maybe, maybe... maybe how we talked pre-game is...
Maybe, like, he's got scared.
I truly thought Fuyoman was gonna throw him out like trash, you know?
I know.
Just taking him out.
Take him out early.
To be fair, I feel like they're in the wrong weight class.
Like...
I feel like that, too.
We should not be fighting Beto right now.
Like...
Beto can be snapped like a goddamn twig at the moment.
Beto has the height, you know?
It gives him a little bit of height.
He does have the height, yeah.
Oh.
Beto, no.
Don't crawl away.
We still have, like, three more minutes of this game.
Beto.
He had to keep going.
Show us the ball grab!
Yeah!
Who is your bet on, Dokie?
My bet?
I think... you know, I feel like the luck might play into it, honestly.
I believe Beto might actually pull through to the finals.
Okay, we'll see.
I mean, it's gonna be interesting to see the guy that, like, was the most underestimated wrestler...
...who had no confidence on himself suddenly pulling through to the finals.
Suddenly pulling through.
Oh!
Beto, I just talked, like, mad shit.
Come on.
Give it up.
That was pretty rough.
I mean, this is how I started, you know?
Yeah, exactly!
Like, Matara pummeled...
You gotta get pushed into a corner.
Come on!
Yeah, Matara pummeled the shitter out of you, but then you made it.
You recovered.
You had the stamina for the long-term gaming.
Oh, and then the fucking grapple throw into the ring.
Oh!
And then the stomp on the head.
He's just casually kicking him, like...
He's not even, like, wrestling.
It's just a street fight.
It's just a regular fight.
I like the fancy little twisty punch he did, though.
The twisty neck.
A little spin.
A little spin and a punch.
Fuyo-man, you gotta be fighting in the ring!
Also, Beto...
Three!
The kiss!
The taunt.
Oh, yeah.
He's blowing you a kiss of good luck, Beto.
You gotta take that to maximize more of your luck.
Oh!
I like that.
And I got his name.
Look at that!
Oh my god!
That kiss made him stronger.
Oh my god.
And the flip!
The flip jump.
And the fucking... Oh my god!
Is this just a fighting game?
Is this just Tekken?
I know those movesets in Tekken!
He plays one Tekken and is now an expert.
Yeah, the one-two-one!
The one-two-one down-up-one?
That was my favorite combo.
Oh my god, we have favorite combo in Tekken.
But it looks like... Oh, but Fuyo-man's gonna grab him.
Is he gonna fucking Bane him?
Oh, and then the first pin!
Oh, the pin!
The pin!
One!
Oh, just one.
Just one.
Still another shot.
Still another shot here for Beto.
What is in Fuyo-man's pants?
I mean... you know what's in his pants.
On the back side?
On the back?
Oh, the back side!
Oh, I see.
You think I meant...
You also know what's in his pants.
I'm being told that it's a coin.
Oh, I see.
I hope it's not a chocolate coin.
No.
But that's how leprechoins make coins!
That's how they fill the coins up.
Oh, what?
Oh, man.
Oh, so close!
He got a two while Fuyo-man got a one.
Come on, Fuyo-man, get up!
Oh, Beto!
Oh, I just see Fuyo-man go into the corner and like down a handful of Lucky Charms and see what happens.
I like how Beto removed one of the cushions in the ring, and then Fuyo-man used it against him.
Beto, no!
You're supposed to use that to your advantage!
Beto!
Oh, come on!
One step away!
He's gargoyling.
Okay.
Oh, oh, oh!
What was the point?
Beto missed, but Fuyo also missed.
I guess like Beto's frail body just couldn't take it.
Throw him out!
And he hits the ring.
Hits the ring.
What is that move called, Mint?
What is he doing right now?
That...
That was a flying...
That was the soaring eagle.
The soaring eagle?
I think that's an actual real wrestling move.
Oh, shoot!
That was in their pen!
One!
Two!
Damn!
I really thought... I really thought...
Oh, my God.
Oh, and another jump kick!
Come on, Beto!
Your pens were all so close!
So close!
Oh, but the...
Oh, is Beto out of stamina?
Oh, this could be bad.
I feel like Beto hasn't really moved that much, if any.
Oh, I like how Fuyo-man moved him from side to side diagonally.
It's like a little house decorating project right there.
Yeah!
That's called the... That's called the Patrick Star, where you...
Take my Beto and move it over there.
I was so close!
The Patrick Star maneuver.
Oh, no.
Fuyo-man is going to tell it to the crowd.
Are you not entertained?
Oh, I'm quite entertained.
This is a great... This is a great match.
Beto, just... You can't just grab him and think it's over, Beto.
You gotta do more than that.
Oh, and then Beto... Oh, he... Did he miss?
I couldn't tell if Fuyo just tripped or he missed.
And he stomps him on the head.
Look at him writhing on the ground.
It's so sad.
Just... Someone...
Someone help this leprechaun.
Someone quick find his pot of gold!
And then Beto jumps out of the ring to do a die.
Beto with his colorful hair.
He's the end of the rainbow.
Oh, oh, and he does a special move.
Oh!
That's gonna hurt.
Oh, but Fuyo-man fucking knees him in the face.
Three!
Come on, guys.
You guys get out of the ring.
You can't pin it outside the ring.
Y'all get in.
Yeah.
Just throwing him around.
Four!
Oh my gosh.
Five!
Are we gonna see them?
Are we gonna see them get timed out?
Both disqualified?
Yeah.
If both get timed out outside the ring, what happens?
Well, are we gonna see it for the first time live on this stream?
No, no, no.
But we could see someone get disqualified.
Oh, seven!
Oh, seven is gonna close!
Beto, knock him out so he can go inside!
Eight!
Oh my god.
Oh, Beto slid in like a ferret.
Is Flu-Met at...
Nine!
No!
Wait, Flu-Met got him D-tiered?
Ten!
Oh my god!
Beto eliminated both diaper players!
The diapers are no more!
Say hello to the diaper denier, the diaper vanquisher, Beto!
Wow.
Oh my god.
I think...
That was just embarrassing for Fuyo!
That was so...
Yeah, Fuyo really started so strong.
It's just...
Wow.
The fact that like she got eliminated from outside the ring, the one of the most embarrassing ways to get eliminated by.
Yeah!
I mean, I guess Beto is just a, you know, he's a potty trainer believer.
I know!
He's teaching all those babies how to use the bathroom, how to use the toilet.
Yeah!
Well, I guess we'll see what Beto says.
And also Fuyo!
Back to the interview stage, I guess.
Yeah!
Fuyo man!
What happened?
Fuyo man beep dee.
Well, I hope you get some good...
Kindness is cruel.
Well, now we know why...
Fuyo man will try, little man, some other day.
Some other day.
Well, I hope you get some good...
I hope it'll be recorded.
I'll record it on my iPhone.
And it's, sadly, past Fuyo man's bedtime.
Bedtime.
Yeah.
Oh, Mr. Beto.
How did you do it?
How did you become the diaper denier?
You know, it's just, you know, I...
I don't know.
I mean, I got flung around like a hacky sack for about 90% of the match.
But I think, I think a little bit of luck actually came in at the end there.
Wow!
Hey.
Nobody expected that from...
You didn't even expect to win yourself.
I can't believe it.
Do you have some... like, do you actually have some self-confidence now?
Yes.
That diaper just got changed.
Fuyomen destroy.
Please get this thing out of here.
I can't do this.
I don't want to do this.
Alright, Fuyomen, come on, it's your bedtime now, Fuyomen.
We gotta take you out to Fuyomen.
Have fun.
Goodbye, Fuyomen.
Bye-bye.
Bero, you will be fighting either Mint or Fillion in the finals.
How do you feel, Bero, to move this far up in this tournament?
You know, I didn't think I'd get this far.
Frankly, I didn't think I'd make it past the first round, but to see myself here, I am just over the moon.
I'm so excited.
But you know what?
I've said it since the beginning.
I'm taking this whole thing.
This whole thing, it's mine.
You want that belt, don't you, Bero?
That belt belongs to me.
Oh, well then.
Well, I guess we'll see who you're going to be fighting next.
Because up next, we have Fillion versus Mint in the semi-finals.
Let's see if Fillion's ready.
Can we bring Fillion into the stage?
Into the interview room?
Fillion.
And kick Bero out?
Yo, what up, gamers?
Alright, Fillion.
Hello.
You're not in the finals yet?
You're in semis.
You're semis.
You're going to be fighting Mint here.
One of our casters.
How many people are the fight?
Two more.
Two more, yeah.
I'm fighting an entire effing army right now.
I feel like effing Leonidas and then like the effing Persians coming at me.
What is this?
I'm feeling good.
You're fighting...
What am I fighting?
Fillion fighting a lot of people.
Who am I fighting?
Mint.
You're fighting Mint, our other caster.
Mint, yeah.
Yeah, this is going to be caster versus caster.
No, I can't do this.
Can I just...
Yeah?
I just want to see y'all duke it out.
Please.
Just like fight each other.
Like, snack talk.
Please.
You know what?
I can't have the caster on caster violence.
There's just no way.
You know what I'm more surprised by?
Like, the fact that Fillion made it this far.
But like, look at her.
She looks emancipated.
She looks like she has no muscle in that... in those bones.
Fillion, are you just going to take that?
Yeah, I mean, I built a beef jerky zombie from Dark Souls 1.
That's my name, by the way.
I know, I know.
But here's the thing.
Here's the thing.
You know who knows Bill like me?
Who?
Luffy.
And he's going to be king of the pirates.
That's true.
Cool.
Also, yeah, I'm not emancipated.
I don't have freedom yet.
So...
Oh.
Yeah.
Wait.
Sorry, I said the wrong word.
Did you mean Amacia?
I thought you...
What's the right way when you're like malnourished?
She looks malnourished like hell.
Okay, I'm malnourished.
Great.
Okay.
This is why Doki got eliminated.
This is why.
I'm sorry.
I don't seem too good here.
Wait, Doki.
I'm literally carrying your legacy right now.
Oh, shit.
You're right.
And you're going to blame me.
Sorry.
Aillion, kick her ass.
Hey, hey, wait a second.
Good luck to you, too.
Mid, defend yourself, Mid.
Mid didn't even get a chance to defend herself.
What did she have to defend, though?
What are you... What are you saying?
What are you talking about?
No one talks shit.
Oh.
Wait, did not... Oh yeah, because I talk shit for her.
Yeah.
Yeah, you did.
Aillion, roaster.
You just let her...
I'm just sitting here.
I'm feeling good.
I'm not gonna roaster.
You're not gonna roaster?
Whoa.
Because she's my friend in the making.
Awww.
As the future king of the pirates meant, if I win, you have to join my army.
My crew.
Oh.
I'm not- Wait, what kind of pirating are we doing?
Pirate.
The legal kind.
I'm making songs off my own.
It's a small time gig, but you know, in the- You know, we'll be mafia in the future.
You know what I'm saying?
Okay.
Mafia?
Uh.
Um.
Is it alright, Fillion, if I wipe your ass?
That's gay.
So.
I mean, hey.
No, no, no.
Listen.
We're not there yet, okay?
Okay.
Let's just wait.
Oh, yeah.
Oh my gosh.
On the ring.
Yeah, on the ring.
To get it started in a ring.
Alright, let's go.
Off to the ring we go.
Alright.
I'm here in the ring.
You're doing your projection right now.
Yup.
Oh my gosh.
Alright, here we go.
Look, I'm loyal to the mission, okay?
Let's start the match now.
Alright, let me make that pull.
You know what would be so sad?
If I lose.
Yeah?
After Fillion has wrestled so many people and I just didn't watch.
That's so true.
It'll be so sad.
Oh my gosh.
She like fought her way here and just showed up.
It's your king of the furry pirates.
It's Fillion making her way to the stage with some weird Fortnite dance.
I love how like, you know like her matches.
Like all she does is flip and it's like, it's so true to her character.
Those are the scariest ones.
Yeah.
Like, like the fact that she does like 20 flips into a kick is so scary.
Just like Luffy.
I don't even remember your move set, Mitt.
All I remember is you crawling away.
That's like...
My move set is get my ass kicked until I'm ready.
Until my masochist points rank up and then I'm like, yeah.
Yeah.
It's like you absorb all the damage in and then like after absorbing all of it, you let out one punch.
One punch with all that damage power.
It's basically how it's true.
There she goes dancing her way.
Dancing her way to freedom.
To the finals.
The carefree ones.
Oh my God.
She's break dancing now.
She's busking.
She's busking for coins, guys.
Oh, if only we could take the coin from Fuyo's...
Fuyo's ass.
Fuyo's ass?
Yeah.
You might want to wash it off a little bit.
Oh shit.
Hello?
Solid Mitt.
It's time for you to get on the stage.
Because Solid Mitt is sneaking in to face off against Fillion.
Give it up for Solid Mitt.
Oh my God.
Mitt, Mitt, she's here.
She's here analyzing the arena again.
Even though she wouldn't.
Even though she shouldn't have this knowledge again.
Okay, it might have changed.
It might have changed in the last ten minutes.
Changed in ten minutes?
I don't know about that, Mitt.
I think you might need to get your head checked after the concussion Matara gave you.
I needed to get my head checked before then, don't you?
Oh, true.
Since you were born.
The doctors were like, maybe there's something wrong.
Since I was born and then I died.
And then I never got it checked out.
Knock, knock.
Is anybody home?
It's me, the champion.
Oh, the future champion right here.
Oh yeah.
He's telling everybody, say my name.
Say my name.
Say her name, chat.
Say her name.
Who said solid farquaad?
Farquaad is in his anime phase right now.
He dyed his hair.
Yeah, you know.
It's a comeback.
It's a look.
It's coming back, everybody.
It's coming back.
She's bringing it back.
She's bringing the Farquaad back.
Oh my god, Fillion lane.
Fillion is so fast.
Yeah, she's so fucking fast.
Oh my god.
I mean look at her build.
It's okay.
Min is absorbing.
You're absorbing all the damage so that you can't do one power kick.
Yummy yummy yummy.
Give me more.
Hurt me more.
Keep pummeling her, Fillion.
Keep pummeling her.
She likes it.
Oh yeah.
Oh my god.
And now she's like, wait, are you getting pinned already?
I don't think so.
No, she's just breaking your... yeah, she's just breaking your wrist.
Oh, she asked the audience and they were like, no don't do it.
That's too much.
No, don't do the wrist breaker.
That's bad in 20 countries.
Oh, and then Fillion picks you up and elbows you in the fucking stomach.
I can't even get a move in.
Yeah, because you're not supposed to.
It's the first two minutes.
Oh, what am I?
What?
What did you do?
What was that, Mint?
What was that move?
I think I did the... I can't even tell you.
I just made it up.
Oh my god.
What a pioneer in wrestling.
Mint literally just made up... wait, already?
One!
Two!
If Fillion lost there, that would be the biggest upset of the century.
It would have been way too quick.
I think I even... I would have been disappointed.
Yeah, even like it just wasn't fair.
It was just fighting.
Like, look at how malnourished she is.
Did he...
Did anyone feed her?
Did anyone feed Fillion at all?
Did we just keep her in a cage?
Is she yellow from being a Simpsons or is she yellow from...
Kidney failure.
From the scurvy?
Yeah, the scurvy.
So, but I feel like we've kept Fillion in a cage since this was announced.
Oh my god, come on, Mint!
Mint, no!
Don't get DQ'd from the outside of the room!
She got a Kodak coil!
She's picking up the code!
I did.
Sorry, she's on a call right now.
She had a cell phone to pick up.
Oh my god, please, somebody...
One!
I feel like there's no way.
We're at the end of the last match for I'm outside the ring.
There's no way it'll be twice in a row.
Right!
You're picking her up and you do a suplex and in a row... wait, it's a continuous grab?
Oh my god!
Two fucking grabs!
What a wall in Tekken terms.
That was a down forward... I'm doing...
I'm doing my original move again.
We should come up.
You know what, Doki, I'll give you the honors.
What do you want to call it?
I think I'll call it scrambling the egg.
Scrambling?
Yeah, you're scrambling her egg right now.
Oh, another pin!
One!
Two!
Going for another round!
Okay, come on.
Alright, if you're gonna go for another round, you should get up instantly at that point.
I know she's gonna have her comeback now.
Yep, she's gonna...
Oh, it's a bait!
It's a bait!
One!
Two!
It was just a bait.
You're in for another fight, Mint.
You're ready to...
I'm ready to go.
Ready to go again.
Oh, and she chucks you out.
I'm ready to go outside the ring.
You wanna go outside, Mint?
You wanna go outside?
Outside?
You said outside?
Oh my god!
She's about to walk the dog.
Oh, she's laughing at me.
This is so embarrassing.
That's a little embarrassing.
We just met each other.
You're really gonna let this zoomer laugh at you?
Oh gosh.
As a hag, are you really gonna let this zoomer do this?
I have more worldly experience, okay?
I can teach a...
You can teach this little kid a lesson?
Yeah.
This is literally like a fight between the old and the new.
Who would win this?
The new... the rookie?
Or the...
Or the boomer?
I mean...
You have to learn from the old to not repeat history, you know?
Oh, that's true.
That's true.
Is she learning anything in that furry brain of hers?
I think she just wants food in that brain of hers.
Right?
When somebody has to get her something.
Another suplex!
Oh my god, the lucky bridge!
The lucky bridge won!
If you got that, that would have been fucking crazy.
That would have been insane.
But she did it with a bracelet on you!
Wait, wait!
Are you tapping out?
No, no, no!
Keep
going!
You can still breathe!
Yeah, I can.
You're not gonna lie, when you did that move earlier, I was like, damn, she's flexible.
Ah!
Oh my god, you're bubbling her!
Oh my god!
She can take a hint.
Grab her tail!
Oh yeah, grab her tail!
Don't let her do this!
She missed!
You dodged it!
Oh, and then some other...
Might be another pin right here.
Oh my god!
It took her down!
A kneecap to the skull!
Oh my god, and the kick to the head!
I picked her up just to bring her down.
Bro, she's spitting on the crowd with how hard you're hitting!
Oh, and she's coming out of the ring.
Running away.
She's getting a reset right now.
That's a tactical reset right there.
It was the concussion.
She didn't know where she was.
Yeah.
She's like...
Come on, pit her!
Yeah!
One!
Two!
Oh, and it wasn't ready.
It wasn't ready.
Fillion, just do the 20 flips!
That's all you have to do, Fillion!
I'll do 20 more!
Oh, and then... what was that?
I don't know.
I think Mr. Farquaad got drunk there.
I was... that was my, like, Spiderman roleplay.
What the fuck?
She brick danced on your face!
Oh, that was pretty...
Oh, that was crazy!
Oh, you're getting another...
You're getting pinned!
Wait, this might be it!
One!
Two!
Not it!
Mitt is ready for another round.
Come on.
And another... and another pin!
Oh my god, wait!
One!
Two!
One more!
I really thought that was it!
Mitt is going one more!
It's not over!
I gotta finish my story!
I'm coming back from the dead.
Oh, she's doing the sneaky.
She's doing the tactical sneak.
Yeah, I'm sneaking, I'm sneaking.
She's sneaking right now.
She's gotta take a break.
She's like, water break.
Why am I taking a break in the corner?
She's like, Give me a sec, I need a water break.
My haggen stinks, I really...
Okay, it could be anyone.
Seriously, the next pin, it's gotta be it.
Oh, but it doesn't look too good for you, Mitt.
It doesn't look too good for you.
I know, I'm pretty tired.
I'm not gonna lie.
She's like, Please, just one water break.
That's all I want.
Oh, she's climbing up.
Miss!
The crowd's cheering her on.
And she hits those!
She...
Wait, what?
Oh, my God!
You teleported her!
breathes out of that!
The teleporting!
How is that legal?
What is she doing?
Another big personal kid.
You really...
You're gonna lose after teleporting!
Oh, no!
One, two!
Teleporting, Mitt!
Your winner heading to the finals is not SolidFarQuad, but it's Philly!
Oh, no!
You know what?
At least I beat Mittara.
That's all that matters.
I can't believe it.
You did the Undertaker teleport behind you move.
But it was just...
I still lost!
That would have been so hard, Mitt!
But it's okay.
It's okay, Mitt.
You did your best.
Now let's go talk to Philly.
She's heading to the finals!
Against a better...
Oh, my God.
Dude, what the hell?
You said...
Whoa, whoa, the audio...
What the fuck?
The audio was like...
Yeah, it was kind of going a little crazy.
Dude, the game is angry!
Mitt Honda was in the fucking game!
Holy shit!
What's going on?
I can't hear it!
It's Discord.
Don't worry.
That was funny.
But, well, Mitt.
Will you be joining Philly's pirate ship?
I guess so.
I guess... I don't know.
What am I gonna have to do?
Swap the poop deck?
Mitt, you were a worthy opponent.
One of the toughest I've ever faced.
And you know what?
I have a spot on my crew just for you.
On the right hand of my ship.
Leading my steering wheel.
What?
She can't drive, though.
Yes, I can.
Shut up!
I can't either.
So we're in the same boat.
Literally.
So, Mitt, I want to say...
I'd be honored.
I thought you were gonna win.
But 90% of that fight, I was on the ropes.
But the moment you teleported behind me, the moment you had that anime moment, I knew I couldn't lose to you.
Because if I did, I would never be able to have someone so strong on my team.
Wow.
I mean, yeah.
You took that moment.
It was like a real shonen protagonist moment where all hope was lost for you.
You manifested it.
You manifested your win.
Yup.
So here's what we're gonna do.
We're gonna go to the grocery store together.
And we're gonna buy a bunch of stuff.
You're gonna pay for it.
And then we'll have a really sick nasty dinner.
Wait, that sounds so normal.
That sounds like such a normal plan from the builder.
Exactly.
Wait, can you cook?
No.
I can make you a cereal.
Yeah.
That's about my level too.
Oh, so you basically hired a maid!
Oh my god!
We can make cereal!
You hired a maid!
You got a maid for your pirate ship!
Wait, true!
I'm a maid, cafe maid.
We don't do anything.
But you can draw pictures on our food.
You can make your own rice.
You can make pictures on our cereal.
There's chefs in the back.
You can take a photo of her.
You can make elf with her cute spells.
Get the elf out of here.
You can make an alphabet cereal.
And you can make words out of it.
Elphabets.
What are we, five?
Wait, I can't spell my name.
Spell her name on her cereal.
Okay, I can help you.
You know what?
That's my job.
You're a babysitter now.
Oh my god.
Well, you are in the finals now.
Did you expect yourself to win?
I'm gonna be honest.
No, but the moment I saw my character hit a triple, double, backflip, quintuple, ultra axe kick on like five different people.
I knew I had something magical.
I feel like Kirito and like I'm against Kayaba right now.
Wow.
Let's call in Beto to the finals.
Oh boy.
You know, you know, this match, this match.
It's not just the finals.
This is personal.
What's the final?
What does Fillion do to you?
You, Fillion, called me Charlie.
Oh.
Was that?
Yeah, I'm so mad about it.
Everyone just called me Charlie now.
You think I like that?
Okay, but you're more critical.
Now look into my eyes.
Doki Bird told me to say it.
Okay, but like as a caster, you should have researched your content.
You should have researched the content.
Hey, hey, hey, I'm gassing you up, okay?
I stand behind Doki Bird.
And I'm here on her legacy.
You all did this to me.
You took my fist and put it through your trolley face.
You understand me?
Oh my god.
She pulled out the Charlie.
She called you by your fake name.
Well, well, then I'll call you David.
David?
My name's not David.
We'll see who takes this.
David and Charlie, congratulations for making it to the finals, everybody.
You got so many people to get here as the final two.
Audience, who do you think is going to take the champion belt home?
Guys, seems like Bettle is currently winning the Polo Spillion.
What?
Oh no.
Wait, how?
Bettle's like a knock-off version of me though.
Is he not?
What the?
I don't care to explain.
Why do eight whips, he does three?
We are not the same.
Do you do the ball grabs though?
I fight with honor.
And I fight for my friends, okay?
And this man has no dignity.
What friends?
Oh no.
Listen up, Charlie.
Your name is Beta.
Your drip is Beta.
And your favorite video game is...
...Bettle.
It's for Betas!
How did you know I liked League of Legends?
Oh no!
She's beyond saving.
Ladies and gentlemen, it speaks for itself.
Well, let's take this fight to the ring.
The final match in this tournament, guys.
Let's see who will take the champion belt.
And off we go.
Wow.
It's been a long, long time.
And I'm so excited.
Two days.
Oh, it has been.
We had so many fighters come in and out.
So many upsets today.
Some of us didn't even make it past the single round.
The finals are here.
Give it up for the Diaper Vanquisher!
There he is.
His last final entrance into the ring.
Will he vanquish another opponent today, Mint?
I... I'm...
I don't know.
I'm feeling pretty...
It's hard to say.
Each has their own strengths.
And so...
It could be anyone's game, honestly.
The thing is...
The thing I'm scared about, and I think that might hurt Betta, is that this time he was actually confident.
I think so too.
And here is your alleged alpha...
FAILURE!
There she goes, doing another dance.
Ready for more coins being thrown at her.
Yup.
She's gotta buy lunch, guys.
Throw coins at her!
She's got... she's starving!
Please!
If you're cold, she's cold!
She's wearing all these shorts and a shirt...
T-shirt, guys!
She can't afford anything.
Right now...
Look at her...
I think...
I think the greatest strength that both of these guys have...
And truly, honestly, the thing that...
That makes them different from the rest, is that they just don't have a single thought behind their eyes.
Oh, that is so true!
That is so true!
Just from the interview process, I could tell...
I could tell they must have repeated 5th grade like 3 times or so Yeah...
Before becoming a streamer.
Oh yeah.
100% There she goes breakdancing one last time.
I do hope Beto's confidence doesn't...
Oh, there's the belt!
The champion WrestleTuber belt!
Yeah, it's beautiful!
Wrestle for that belt, guys!
My hero academia.
I hope Beto's confidence doesn't, you know, hurt him in the end.
That's like... because like every match he got through, he was not confident at all.
Yeah, exactly.
It was like that... being pushed into...
Oh, that is... one, two...
Okay, it's a match ended there.
Oh, Finn!
What's going on?
Beto!
What?
Oh my god, he's getting spanked like a bad child!
Bad child!
Bad baby!
Oh my god, that double jump on the ring!
Oh, on the rope too!
I feel like they share one brain cell together.
I think so too.
Yeah, I think he...
Look, they're dancing together.
Oh my god.
He should... Holy shit!
Beto, where was those moves in the last day?
Whoa!
Oh my god, he's confident right now!
Confident Beto!
That could bite him in the butt though.
Not gonna lie, confident Beto is scary.
I'm seeing moves...
What is going on?
Okay, I... Oh my god, so he's the ring around the Rosie.
What do you mean?
Yeah.
Another pin?
What?
He's tired already.
Oh, I do!
Come on, Tails!
Get up, Tails!
Okay, but did you see how Beto was heavily breathing there from just like one minute of fighting?
It's true, it's true.
Oh my... she's flipping...
She's flipping...
She's just showing off in there.
The chat donated 500 bits for a flip, so she's got a...
Do a flip, VTuber!
Do a flip!
Oh my god, the sound alert is going off.
And 500 bitties, thank you for the 500 bitties on Twitch for a billion.
Oh man, Beto's back in the ring though.
Oh, another pin!
Another pin!
Oh, this is it.
Look at his face.
He's not ready.
He is ready to keep on wrestling.
Yeah.
But he's a little tired.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
And Fillion missed again.
Missed again.
Okay, Beto back to the ring.
Back to the ring and then a fucking grapple with his legs!
Oh!
Another pin.
Do the countdown, Min.
Come on, Fillion gets trolled!
One!
Oh, it's just one.
Just one.
This is intense.
Honestly, it could be anybody's game.
Seriously, it could be anyone's game.
Yeah.
Like, they all seem like...
seem like they could take it home.
Oh!
The taunt!
Whoa!
Oh, I feel like Fillion just has more speed stats than him.
I think so too.
Beto might be really lucky.
But like, is luck gonna save him if she's just so fast?
And she just flips for fun.
Yeah.
And everyone keeps redeeming Flip.
Guys, stop donating 500 biddies!
She has to wrestle!
Oh!
Stop, guys!
Come on.
Oh, come on, Beto!
Get up!
He's gonna have a comeback.
She's gonna come back.
He's gonna come back when we least expect it.
That has been the majority of his matches.
Fillion does another Flip.
Oh!
But Beto blocks it with his Knives!
He denied it!
Oh, but the Crouch Kick...
The Cranium Check.
Okay, but like, remember when Fillion said that she would never win?
Never stoop that low to target the balls?
We just saw her hit a nut shot!
Is there no integrity anymore?
And another rope break!
Are you serious?
A rope break?
The very first rope break of the whole tournament!
Yeah, I think so!
Wait, another?
One!
Two!
Oh, that was so close!
That was so close!
We thought it was over!
I thought so.
I was ready to call it!
Oh, and another Flip.
Not so fast, not so fast though.
These are two wild cards.
They're so wild.
Honestly, I felt like the ref might have been paid off.
That should have been three!
I counted in my head and it was three.
Hey, what are you saying, Dokia?
Are you saying this is not fair?
Well, I'm not saying it.
I'm implying it.
Isn't this your tournament?
No!
Didn't you and Matara kill off the majority of my staff?
Oh, just the guards!
We're not touching the referee!
We don't care about them!
Well, considering I lost, maybe we should have.
I mean, the refs are now scared for their safety after what you've done, so maybe they got paid off for more protection!
We're already at seven.
Oh my god.
Wait, where's eight?
There's no more countdown?
We were at six!
Oh, seven!
Seven!
There it is!
No, don't bring her back!
What are you doing, Petal?!
What are you doing?!
You could de-cute her off of the ring!
Oh!
Oh?
Did he slip?
What's going on?
Banana peel there?
Yeah, the loony...
We call that the loony tunes, everybody!
Oh, oh my god!
The...
Oh!
And Petal denied!
Intercepted!
He intercepted!
Oh!
But it doesn't matter!
It doesn't matter!
Is she gonna pin him?
Oh!
There's the countdown!
Where's the count?
The rep!
What's going on, rep?!
What?!
Then we just see!
Oh, what?!
One!
Two!
Oh, and that hit denial!
I...
Guys, I think... I think... I think the rep...
I think this is a rigged match!
Oh!
Here we go!
One!
Two!
Petal's here for another.
What?
Feline gets trolled.
Where'd the lights go, guys?
Oh!
Where'd the lights go?
This is so rigged!
Oh my god!
She copied the move!
It doesn't matter!
Bella tried to do another...
She knew what to do!
She knew what to do after me!
She knew... Yeah, she downloaded your moveset and knew how to counter it!
What if there was a second teleport?
Oh!
That is crazy!
Oh my god!
Petal is maxing that luck right now!
That did not look good for Feline.
That looks like it's definitely her.
Oh, her legs.
She ain't flipping anytime soon anymore.
I don't think so.
No!
He's getting rid of all her appendages so she'll never flip again.
It's because she doesn't get enough calcium!
Her bones are brittle.
Someone throw her an orange.
Oh, no!
If you're gonna be throwing things in the ring, she needs that orange right now.
She's like Popeye.
She grabs a can of spinach and like eats it and becomes strong.
Oh my god!
Petal reset the count so it's back to four.
Petal, stop putting her back in the ring!
Oh!
And the knockout of the ring!
You're not allowed in this ring anymore.
Petal, you have to come back in the ring.
Oh, I can't.
Oh, Billion jumped out as well!
I think she reset the count by jumping out.
I think so too.
We'll find out soon if it goes back to one.
I don't see an eight.
Yeah, she reset it.
Time to count, everybody.
He's going back in.
You know what comes after two?
I mean, one.
I think we need a teacher here.
Oh my god.
Oh, Billion was trying to fucking flip on her but he ended up flipping on her!
And another flip!
This is it.
Oh, Petal's doing a little dance.
Like, cheer me on.
The taunt.
Oh!
Billion's not happy.
Oh, wait!
One!
Two!
Oh, so close!
So close.
Come on, the crowd's getting restless.
Come on, Billion!
The crowd needs to know if you're gonna lose or win!
Oh, another jump.
Oh, it's gonna hit.
We got a cutscene.
It's gonna hit!
Oh, that's gotta hurt.
That's gotta hurt.
But he's not gonna pin though, Mint.
Yeah, he's not done playing around with her.
Oh!
And another one.
Oh, here we go, here we go!
One!
Two!
Three!
Your winner for WrestleTuber 2020!
Four!
The Charlie Denier!
The Diaper Destroyer!
The Baby Girl himself!
Maddo!
Insane.
That was actually... that was the most insane match I've seen today, Mint.
Absolutely.
It was worthy of the finale.
The fact that the ref just disappeared for five seconds.
What's this win deserved?
I don't know, let's talk to Beto.
Let's ask Beto what the fuck was that?
Yeah, Beto.
Before anyone makes any accusations, I did not pay the ref.
Okay?
I don't know what that was.
That wasn't me.
Just totally a fair and normal game.
Sure.
Yeah.
Uh-huh.
So where did that ref go?
That was a really fair game.
They were tying their shoe, you know?
They were tying?
Who knows?
Counting the money that was slipped into their pocket.
Yeah.
I'm gonna show the fans what your championship thing looks like real quick.
So there he is!
The winner of WrestleTuber Championship.
Some would say it might not be deserved.
Others would say he was just lucky.
And the ref, you know, he had something in his eye, you know, during one of those crucial moments.
We'll never know.
Hey, Fillion, how do you feel?
Alright, well, I'm not gonna say it was rigged.
Okay, we're gonna say it.
But it was rigged.
Yeah.
Now, I will say it was a really fantastic tournament, you know?
I had a really great time here.
I didn't think it would make it this far.
But I'm gonna say this.
The worst thing position ever is to go through an entire tournament just to lose the very ninth place.
I will never forget this day.
This thing will burn until WrestleTuber 2025.
And I will come back stronger than ever.
And I'll be on gear.
Oh, yeah.
We're looking forward to it.
Yeah, I'm gonna do my best Lance Armstrong impression.
And you guys can get swept.
Damn.
Well, that is some fighting words.
I guess we'll see if Fillion will get a rematch in 2025.
And next year.
Well, Fillion, we have to lead you out of the interview stage because we got to interview the winner now.
So, sorry.
As the loser, you might have to leave.
It's alright.
You did amazing, though.
I'm so proud of you.
You did great, though.
You made it this far.
And you made a lot of friends, right?
You made a lot of friends?
Yeah, you made friends.
Yeah.
Yippee.
Don't do it.
I'll take my leave.
And I'll take my crew with me after.
Alright.
Well fought.
Good luck.
I'll see you there.
Well, Betel, you had you were the least confident out of all of our contestants.
And oh, God.
I fucking won.
I told you.
I told everybody.
I said it.
I would win.
And look at me now.
Look at me, Mom.
I did it.
Is he okay?
I don't think so.
Did he get bit by Mary earlier?
I don't think he's okay guys.
Is he crying?
I think he's crying.
Steph, we might need some tissues real quick.
It's just a game.
You did great.
How do you feel being such a winner and holding that championship belt?
You know, it feels good.
I had some brothers in this and this.
I had to kill my brother to get here.
Oh, you do?
You know, I fought my brother in the ring.
He fought his brother.
He fought his twin.
He fought battle too.
I had to absorb his nutrients to become more powerful.
Wait, that means you were fighting as two!
You had literally two battles in you!
I had two.
We fused to become the perfect life form.
So it was a 2v1 this entire time.
Liquid battle.
Liquid battle, yeah!
I'm liquid battle?
Liquid battle.
Liquid dies!
No way!
I'm not liquid battle.
I can't believe it.
Battle here will be holding on to that champion belt.
To represent the winner of the very first WrestleTuber 2024.
No one will stop him.
Unless...
Oi,
dude.
This is not gonna work at all.
This is really .
No one has enough energy.
Please
don't pick that up at home, he will be satisfied.
Ah, oh man, that fatto.
Me too.
Did I Francisco?
Your security guard turned out to be a bug in disguise inside my phone.
Because you killed my original security guard!
We now have a new contender?
Who are you, sir?
Who are you?
I'm the hero.
Sir, are you okay?
What is this?
Are you okay?
Sir?
The vocal fry!
Oh my god!
Oh my god, I'm scared, Fettle.
Are you scared?
I'm scared.
I don't have to fight them, do I?
Oh, you're fighting this 3D man right now.
What?
Come with me, man.
Come with me, Pedro.
It's not over, Fettle.
You gotta defend your title.
Already?
Where's my belt?
Oh no!
It's over there, sir!
It's over there!
No, no, no.
Please don't hurt us.
Alright, battle's over.
Good luck, Fettle!
Off to the ring we go!
Good luck, everybody!
Where's my belt?
Oh my god!
The secret matchup!
We have another invasion of WrestleTuber!
Who could've thought that another intruder would happen?
Yeah, we thought there would be like one, but... three?
Three intruders!
This is what happens when there's no more security in this event, guys.
And WrestleTuber keeps you on your toes, everybody.
I can't believe it!
Bro, Fettle has to fight a 3D prince!
He has to fight a shadow.
What is this?
Kingdom Hearts?
What's going on here?
Fighting Shad.
Oh my god.
Did someone say the door to darkness?
WrestleTuber 2024 is not over yet!
Your champion for now...
Battle!
Oh man.
I mean, he's showing the world.
He's showing the world a belt that he literally...
just won like two minutes ago.
Yeah.
He's attached to it.
He likes it.
It would be very embarrassing if he loses it in just like...
you know, after holding onto it for like five minutes.
He already wrote it into his will.
He might have to rewrite again.
He's flexing.
He's like showing everybody, look!
Look, guys!
I did it, guys!
I won the belt, guys!
Look!
He has a pretty heavy belt too, you know?
He's probably already tired.
Oh my god, I know.
Like he's already wasting his endurance right now.
Fero, you have a match!
Fero!
You have a match with Yuusan!
You can't just use all of your energy now!
He's gonna gloat a little.
And just like in Pokmon, when Gary became champion, five minutes later, a new champion might be on the horizon.
It's Yuuuuma!
Who is that on the screen?
He's gonna blow... they're gonna blow your mind.
I think, you know, the next evolution after human is human.
Human.
We are witnessing history.
Yuusan is the next level of evolution right now.
I'm afraid for Beto.
Beto is like tired from all the wrestling he did.
Just for a secret opponent to just show up?
Mind freak.
He's here to freak your mind.
Wow!
Look at it!
Oh my god.
You know what?
Yuusan just won by performance alone.
Holy...
Time out.
Touchdown!
Oh my god.
It's not over yet.
You know what?
Yuusan, fan service.
Giving the fans what they want right now.
Oh yeah.
I don't know.
Beto looks pretty puny next to this guy right now.
That was gonna be...
Oh shit.
Oh my god!
That's definitely the wrong weight class.
Holy shit.
He just falls to the ground.
It's okay Beto.
You can do it.
Just get up.
Beto get up.
Beto you got this.
Oh my god.
Yuusan.
The arms are limp.
What the fuck?
Beto please.
Wait.
It's a fucking double flip into Beto.
Not only can you man show off but also show up.
Oh my god.
To be fair.
Yuusan hasn't failed.
He hasn't fought anybody since his first match.
He's primed and ready.
They're primed and ready to beat the shit out of Beto right now.
Yuusan's not even doing moves to hurt Beto.
He's just showing off.
Yeah.
Oh!
To the face.
Okay.
Hey there's a child there.
Let's play a little game.
I'm gonna let you to do it fair you guys.
Hey!
Spin on the child!
The child will remember it forever!
He'll absorb the power!
He'll absorb your power and absorb the nutrients just like how Beto absorbed his twin.
Yuusan's like is this what you want?
Take him.
I don't want him.
Take out the trash.
Come on Yuusan.
Come on Beto.
Where's your max luck?
Your max luck should overpower any of your skills!
Anything!
Guys, I...
Guys...
I think I feel a little bit bad.
He's tired.
He like totally let his guard down thinking he was done with all these matches.
He unclenched, you know?
He was fully clenched up during the entire tournament.
And he thought... Beto thought it was just over.
Wait, is it?
Uh oh.
Wait.
Oh!
What in the blitz!
Oh no, he's just emoting in the ring.
No way.
It took all of five minutes.
But we, um...
Yeah.
We have a new champion!
Human!
Oh.
Hahaha.
I...
Well, uh...
I'm not gonna lie, I totally looked away for one minute, and it actually fucking happened.
Well, um...
That was...
That was inter...
I...
Well, that was a slaughter, man.
Like...
You fell is really emoting in the state...
What do we do?
Hahaha.
Hahaha!
I guess let's talk to Bettle and Ysane.
Oh, what happened?
Hey guys!
Did I win?
Yeah, hang on.
No!
We had the title for 14 seconds!
You tongue out!
It's okay!
It's okay, Bettle!
It's okay, you know...
Like...
It's just... you know... I mean, look at this!
Like, you really think...
How was I supposed to win?
You really think you could win against that?
No!
No...
This is...
This is terrible!
Um...
How did it feel to be a winner for five minutes, Bettle?
Well, I...
Well, it felt great.
It felt great.
I'm happy to be a winner of something for about five minutes, but...
I just lost it already!
I'm so proud of you, man.
I'm proud of you.
You're the real Chad.
You did so well, man.
Wow!
Thanks, you man!
No problem.
We witnessed it!
We witnessed the mystery in the making by the first evolution...
The next evolution...
Of humankind!
One day, it will be just like you saw it!
One day...
You man!
What are your words to your fans, to your audience?
What do you have to say?
Um...
Check my music video.
Is this a self-promo?
Wow!
You man will be back behind the building selling mixtapes, everybody.
Yeah, yeah!
After the show!
Actually, watch my music video.
If you guys want a signed copy of you man's music album, come outside backstage for the VIP pass where Chad buys an autographed you man album.
I guess Beto will also be there, I guess, too.
What will you be selling, Beto?
I don't know.
Nothing?
Just be there!
I'll just stand there, I guess.
It's okay.
Second place is not too bad.
That means Billion got third.
Yeah.
Yeah, you got second!
I mean... wait, I got... well, I mean, I got first, then second.
Yeah, but... yeah.
What does that equate to?
Second place, because it was the last second.
Nothing!
No!
Okay.
Great.
No!
I'm glad I have spoken.
All right, well, we're gonna take it back to the main casting room.
Thank you, guys.
Thank you, Beto, Yusan.
Thank you for being here.
Even though Yusan did break in and took away that man's happiness that he felt.
Like, he was the happiest he's ever been in his whole life.
And he took it, and they took it away within five minutes.
But anyway...
I'm sorry, man.
Yeah, you did well.
Bye-bye.
Thanks, guys.
Thanks, everybody.
It was great being a winner for 14 seconds.
It doesn't hurt at all.
Yeah, just be better next time.
It's okay.
Yeah, okay.
Yeah, they want me to fight God.
What was I supposed to do?
You tried your best, man!
You tried your best!
That's all that matters!
You fought God and lasted, like, at least three minutes.
You know?
That's an accomplishment.
But you don't succeed!
I mean, he's right.
You're a great announcer.
Yeah.
Thanks.
All right.
We're gonna be back to the main stage real quick for Min and I.
We're gonna see you guys at the main stage, guys.
All right.
Wow.
What a night.
I don't even know what to say about all of that.
That was...
pretty crazy what we experienced tonight.
Yeah.
Truly one for the books, I think.
You know, I felt like, you know, like, we should end it with Royal Rumble.
But with, you know, you, you, man's invasion, I felt like that was, like, the perfect way to, like, end the whole event.
And what an event, Min.
What an event.
Like, there were so many things that happened.
Like, the fact that, like...
Fuyo made it so far and, like, pioneered the diaper meta just to get defeated by Bettle.
And then Bettle won just to lose it in 14 seconds.
We saw ball grabbing.
We saw diaper grabbing.
We saw titty grabbing.
We saw head grabbing.
We saw every sort of grabbing that we could have grabbed.
And you know what?
You, man, grabbed the title.
And the belt right off of...
Right off of Bettle's body.
Bettle stood no chance.
That, that, man...
Oh, my.
GUSA was fucking built there.
Oh, yeah.
I was like...
Oh, my God.
I felt like...
Like, GUSA was just fucking flipping.
And, like, the fact that, like, they ended it with a flip while Bettle was...
I know.
...stayed lying on the ground in his pool of blood outside the ring.
Just so sad that he was fighting again.
He was like, why am I here?
Why am I here just to suffer?
Just Bettle luck next time, I guess.
Ooh.
I guess you gotta come.
How are you feeling, Dokie, after, you know, pulling off such a crazy event?
It feels, feels like...
It's crazy.
It feels like I'm speechless in a way.
Like, there's no words to really describe how I really feel right now.
There was some stuff along the way, but everybody enjoyed the experience, the time, the fans, the participants.
You should have seen the Discord while the matches were going on.
Oh, yeah.
Like, the cast, the staff, and, like, the participants were just, like, laughing along the way with some of the stuff that was going on.
Mid, how do you feel casting for this after breaking in?
Oh, it was great.
Thank you for having me.
And, you know, sorry that I, like, kind of just can't...
Sorry that I killed, like...
But, hey, but, you know, think of it.
I killed off a bunch of guys, so you don't have to pay them.
Oh, that's true.
That's true.
Easy peasy.
That is so true, Mid.
But, like, some would say you're the reason why Beto lost, like, his belt.
Wait, what do you mean by that?
Because by you killing the security guards, you started the domino effect of all these other contestants coming in because we had no more security.
Um, I...
I don't know.
I think what the other thing I have to say about that is, if you were a real champion, you would be able to beat anybody that comes in through that door.
Sounds like a good strategy.
So, even if it's Grandpa or Joe...
So, Beto did not deserve the belt.
Sorry.
Sorry, Beto.
Beto next time.
We're all going to have to wait.
Before we call it.
We got to thank some people for this event.
I'm really sad that I failed.
For the people that made the graphics, everything from here, the videos and everything.
First off, as you guys can see, the logo, belts and graphics were done by SugarType, Melly and OniPilot.
A huge shoutout to them for making the assets for those things.
We also have other people who thank, like the trailer video and the singers.
The last minute... I think... sorry, my...
Katara.
It says Katara from Avatar The Last Airbender.
Katara!
Amazing!
Oh my god, Katara was here too, guys?
Holy shit!
It's okay, it's Katara-mine, you guys.
It wasn't actually Katara, she was here in spirit.
It was Katara.
Katara's spirit name has a different name.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
And her name is Katara.
She inspired the original... the Katara from Avatar The Last Airbender.
It was based off of Matara.
Yeah, yeah.
But yes, we want you guys to know, like those intro videos, like the Mint and Matara intro videos were done like...
basically on the day of their period.
It's like I received the Matara video like this morning.
This morning.
So a huge shoutout to Hebe and Nightden.
And then...
Finally, we have also the...
the backgrounds that was done.
The stadium background was done by JL.
And the fanart compilation, the video that you saw during the intermission and the starting stream and the outro in the end...
was done by Rabbit Hole.
So they looked through all the fanart and put it all together into the video for us.
So a huge shoutout to them.
And finally, a shoutout to everyone that participated.
All the contestants.
All the wrestlers.
The staff team.
For giving up their time.
Being here.
Like all those hours being here.
Doing the interviews.
Doing the announcements.
Doing the casting.
They all gave up their time to be here participating in this event.
And so we gotta give them a shoutout.
My throat is dying after casting for two hours.
Can I go home now?
Sorry.
Yeah.
Huge...
Great...
Great announcing.
Man, you did amazing for your first time.
This guy was so nervous.
Oh, thanks.
He was so scared.
I was.
I was shaking.
Yeah.
It was crazy.
How do you feel announcing for WrestleTuber?
I'm fucking tired.
Bro, I...
My head is like slightly lightheaded.
I was like, man, I guess I did use a lot of oxygen.
I'm beat.
Yeah.
We're all tired.
But it's...
It's almost over, guys.
It's almost over.
And finally, a shoutout to Gamersupps for sponsoring this tournament, this event.
They paid for everything.
Basically, I didn't have to pay for any of the stuff like the belts, the...
The belts, the graphics, the videos, all that stuff that I said all these people made.
I didn't have to pay for it.
Gamersupps kindly decided to pay for all of this.
So thank you again to Gamersupps.
Well, this is the end of the show, everybody.
My throat is dead.
Do you have any final words, Mint, to tell the audience?
Nope.
Okay.
All I gotta say...
Is see you next year.
Yes.
See you all next year for WrestleTuber 2025!
Yeah!
Bye, everybody!
Bye-bye!
Thank you, guys!
Bye -bye!
Bye-bye!